Turn on the lava lamp.
He knows how to turn it on.
Everything.
His name is young Jamie.
Three,
two,
one.
I'm live with Nick Swardson,
former drug dealer.
Tell us your tale.
Tell us your tale of.
Of Youth Gone Wild.
It's a tale of youth gone wild.
Wild.
How many people like broke windows?
Because they heard that song,
but like wild.
Finally somebody labeled at we use in
songs could be inspiring in a bad way
sometimes.
Right?
Get you to do some stupid shit.
Did you know any people carelessly
whispered?
I know fucking careless.
Do how many people woke people up before
they woke them up?
They were not ready to go.
They weren't planning on going solo cod.
Yeah.
I'm going to host a lot of fucking
people this year.
When you stop and think about George
Michael Prince,
who is the latest one?
There was some big one in Lincoln Park.
Chester Bennington.
This task faster.
That was a big one.
And Chris Cornell both in the same way.
Yeah.
And then he committed suicide on his
birthday to birthday do.
Yeah.
That was a really.
That was a weird one,
man,
that guy was 41 on top of the world,
the lead singer,
one of the biggest rock bands of all
time,
but it's hard to say like what caused
him to be so fucked up,
but most people point to he was very
sexually abused when he was a young kid
and that just,
he never,
he just never recovered from that.
And then,
you know.
Yeah,
I never knew him,
but I had friends that are really close
to them and they just said he was the
most gentle,
sweet guy.
Fucking powerful voicemail.
Shred.
Powerful.
Yeah.
No,
it's horrible.
It's so hard for people to understand
that you could be the lead singer of
like,
I mean,
arguably one of the biggest bands of our
generation.
Yeah.
Giant,
huge arena filled up.
There was a photo of him standing on
stage with no shirt on and this massive
arena show and everybody had their cell
phone lights on.
You know,
people do that now instead of lighters.
I was a kid when I was a boy.
We didn't have cell phone.
We burned bodies.
We had fire and we had fucking fire
hazard,
but he was,
um,
he was standing on stage and I was like,
yeah,
that's the photo.
Like,
look at that Shit,
man.
That's no one could ever possibly
imagine that that guy would not be
insanely happy.
I mean,
look how many people love that guy.
You,
you're just getting a tiny fraction of
the love that guy must've gotten and it
still wasn't enough.
Yeah.
So hard to understand.
I mean,
yeah,
that level of just in her sadness and
darkness.
Good Lord.
It's just awful to think of.
That guy went through to get to that
point and he had six kids.
Yeah.
So I mean,
it's just like,
it had to be so much that even having
kids and being with his kids wasn't
enough.
Fuck man,
that's a crazy picture though.
That's a sick photo.
Oh,
mine.
All the way up in the rafters.
Yeah,
I mean that's probably like 30,000
people or something crazy.
Yeah.
Well look at all the people that don't
have phones.
Yeah.
What's their deal?
Losers.
Maybe they're just cheap mirror.
They're like,
Ari,
like maybe they just went flip phone.
I can't handle it,
can't handle the APPS.
It's just too much.
Too much temptation.
Always resisting and he's going to be
chopping his own.
Would soon are,
he's going to have a.
well,
I guarantee you.
He told me you wanted to buy land and I
was like,
do you want to like build a house?
He goes,
no,
just want to camp there.
I was like,
what?
Buy Land to camp on.
He's going to buy like land,
but he's not going to build a house like
land land or like camping.
He's kids.
Was that.
They were calling it glamping,
which is camping with them.
It was him.
Big Jay Oakerson.
Big J posted on his instagram page,
but he loves being outside.
He loves nature.
They just.
I mean,
I get it.
Look if you can camp,
if you really don't need a house,
what do you need?
Do you need a trailer to keep your shit
in?
Like a trailer to put pots and pans and
if.
Yeah,
if you still want shit.
You know what I mean?
You can't,
can't have posters anymore,
but yeah.
No poster template.
Farrah Fawcett on the roof of your tent.
Youth Gone Wild poster up.
Yeah.
How many fucking go camping?
Why do you have to like buy that's
outside camping.
If you're.
If you own a plot of land and then
you're just sleeping on it,
is that technically camping?
That's a very good point.
That's sleeping on your land.
That's like if you're hunting and
there's a fence around the animals and
you're only on one acre.
Exactly.
Is that really hunting?
Fucking hunting.
Just chasing down shit that can't run
away.
Yeah.
You're feeling you're not camping.
No.
Bears are going to just wander up by
your campsite.
Nope.
That's part of the thrill of being a
camper.
You're out there for real in the wild.
Yeah.
You can't be on your own little land
unless your land is huge,
but then if you land it's huge and yet
it's like say if you have like one of
those ranches in Texas,
you know,
Texas is like something insane.
Amount of Texas is private land.
It's not a lot of public land in Texas.
It's just all giant ranches and some of
them are like 10,000
plus acres,
like twenty thousand one hundred
thousand.
Like you could camp there I guess
because it takes you like three hours to
drive across it.
That's weird.
He had drove to your house.
That's too much land too much,
right?
It's too much.
Why do you need that much land?
How about Ted Turner?
Doesn't that guy owns the most land of
anybody in the country here today?
King ranch sprawls 825,000
acres of South Texas.
Land an area larger than the state of
Rhode Island.
Oh my gosh.
Are you kidding me?
As the home of 35,000
cattle and over 200 quarter horses,
king ranch,
one of the largest ranches in the world
today.
I wonder if they hunt on that ranch.
Who?
Which king?
Some fucking baller.
He might as well be a case King of Rhode
Island.
Burger King.
Maybe it's a burger king guy.
Isn't sane man.
That is insane.
No gay bars.
I get this three or four in there for
sure.
It would be amazing.
No gay bars,
but there's plenty of truck stops.
Rest stops are like where they're at
now.
They haven't really gotten to the full
on gay bar,
not full admittance.
They just wanted to meet at the rest
stops when we were kids.
That was like the thing like you'd
always know.
The dudes would try to bang dudes at
arrest a hundred percent.
Like if you're at a rest stop and
someone knocks on your door and it's a
dude.
He's looking to get a blow job.
Just no rest there.
Nobody's resting.
You're wide awake and in your mouth they
figure out to meet at rest up.
So I've always wondered like how does
that work?
CB radio,
breaker breaker one nine.
I'm looking to suck some Dick.
Anybody out there hollaback?
Sixty nine or 69 or come on and rigor.
Rigor.
One night I like to make bathroom smell
of Shit excites me over.
Was it a senator or whatever the
politician was.
The gentleman who got arrested in a
sting operation because so many dudes
were sucking dicks in the bathroom at
the airport in Minneapolis where I'm
from.
Yeah.
Then people called me about it.
I was like,
what the fuck?
I don't know.
Hey Man,
what's the airport?
What's the stole?
Was it how many taps?
It'd be so many people that they
actually went and put a cop there to try
to bus people.
I mean,
how many people have to get their dick
sucked in a place before they hire a
cop?
We found a hotspot.
So here it is.
Senator pleaded guilty reportedly after
bathroom stall incident.
That's Minneapolis St Paul Airport.
Yeah.
And he was,
uh,
he was like tapping on the ground.
They had a way a dad that was a tap
move.
Yeah.
Okay.
What is,
he said at the time of the incident
incident,
I complained to the police.
They were misconstrue my actions.
I was not involved in any inappropriate
conduct.
He said I should have had the advice of
counsel and resolving this matter in
hindsight,
I should not have pled guilty.
I was trying to handle this matter
myself quickly and expeditiously get it.
And I travel wearing tap shoes.
See,
part of me thinks it's hilarious,
but part of me is sad that this guy has
to like hide what he's into and he has
to hide in bathroom stalls and learn
some fucking secret tap and just smell
farts from around the world as he's
coming.
According to the report cited by roll
call,
Craig tapped his right foot,
which the officer said he recognized as
a signal used by persons wishing to
engage in lewd conduct.
But what if you were there and you just
tapping your foot?
Yeah.
What if you're just impatient because
your shit's taking other stuff next.
Oh,
he also then entered the stall next door
and block the door with his luggage.
Oh Gee.
What does that.
How does P,
other people get in then?
Oh my God,
I was in there with somebody.
He was trying to block anybody from
coming in.
Oh my God.
He must've been just going to town on
guys and then airport.
That was the spot and people are kicking
trying to kick in the door.
What was happening there?
I got it,
but how does it like.
How does a spot become notorious?
Like how does arrested,
what does it say?
Proceeded to swipe his hand under the
stall divider several times.
I want to know what the fuck was.
The cop was saying,
if he was like,
stop.
I can't do it.
I can't Tuck your tick here.
We don't know what the cop was saying.
The cop was totally leading him on.
I mean it sounded like he had the green
light.
Unless the guy's a total psychopath.
When you go into a stall with another
dude and you stack up your luggage in
front of the door,
that's a bold move.
It's weird.
It seems like you would only do that if
you were emboldened.
Didn't just tap his foot.
He touched the officer's foot with his
foot.
He reached his foot all the way under.
Here's my question.
We know cops are full of Shit.
All right.
Just like people.
People full shit.
Put cops are people.
Not all cops.
A lot of cops are awesome.
We know some cops are full of shit.
Like when when something like this
happens,
I feel like that's one person versus
another person.
I don't really feel like a cop's word is
worth more than a regular person's word
because I think a cop was just a regular
person.
I think you should listen to them when
they're doing the job,
but something like this,
it might've been exactly as this cop
described,
but it might've been like that Baltimore
cop that got busted planting drugs with
his fucking camera had a body camera on,
and what he didn't understand is when
you turn on a body camera,
it records 30 seconds before you turned
it on,
so just in case you turn it on in a
moment of duress was something crazy is
going on.
You're like,
shit,
the camera and you present on vacancy.
Someone committing a crime,
perhaps you have a 32nd buffer.
I didn't know that.
He didn't know that either.
Dude.
So they got on video,
30 seconds of him going back in planting
the drugs that he then pretended to.
Oh fine.
Oh my God.
That's horrifying.
Horrible.
Fucking horrifying,
horrible.
See?
Because if you're gonna be able to
convict somebody on,
this guy says this and that guy says
that,
and who do you believe?
I believe the copies an officer of the
law.
That's crazy because it's just a person
and this is not a disrespectful thing.
It's cops.
I'm not,
I'm not a disrespectful person,
but the amount of power is a scary
amount of power and it's just a person.
Now,
some people like I have a bunch of
friends are cops and they know how to
handle it.
You know,
they've handled it and they've,
they,
they get it,
they know what it is and they're real
cool about it.
Like big John McCarthy,
the ref for the UFC.
He's one of the best examples.
Big John is a.
He was a serious cop in,
involved in some fucking hairy shit for
years.
One of the nicest guys you ever want to
meet and totally fair and reasonable
guy.
And he was the guy,
you know,
that was like a bright and shining
example of what a cop could be.
And if the world is filled with big John
McCarthy's as cops,
it'd be a wonderful place and I think we
all figured out,
but cops are just people,
men,
especially when these cops are going
into these situations,
like imagine me in a 21 year old guy or
however the fuck old you are,
and all of a sudden you're working in
Camden,
New Jersey.
I get the fuck Outta here.
You're not ready for that.
You're saying regular dude and you're
going to get thrust into some chaotic,
almost semi war zone in some of these
bad neighborhoods.
These people have to patrol.
Yeah.
And just another world with another set
of rules and just shit.
Just going down and you're coming up on
is most likely a threat to your life.
You pull a guy over,
like you pulled a guy over in a 65
impala.
What are the odds that guy doesn't have
a gun,
right?
You see like one of them low rider cars
and you see some,
some gangster look and fellows with some
crazy face tattoos and shit and they're
driving those cars.
Can you imagine having to pull over
someone who you knew was probably
willing to shoot you and you have to
talk to them about their brake light
being off or they were five miles an
hour above the speed limit.
You,
you know the videos,
you've seen videos of cops getting shot.
We have,
you know that that could happen.
You around.
People just lying all the time.
They're all lying.
Yeah.
How many of them are telling the truth?
They talked to you.
Ninety percent fellowship.
Ninety percent.
So every day it's just true
panic.
I mean like when I would get pulled
over,
I mean like I panicked.
I fucking like,
yeah,
that cop,
that shot,
that chick,
the recent one where the woman called in
Minnesota.
Yeah.
She called for the police and then she
came out and when she came out the cops
shot her.
That to me is the perfect example of why
we should reassess what a cop is and
reassess like how many people get to be
cops.
It's an extraordinary responsibility
you're putting on just any person,
an ordinary person.
I would say.
I think you have to be an extraordinary
person to be a good cop for sure.
You also have to deal with the fact that
there's been a lot of bad cops and
there's a lot of prejudice against cops.
It was like two giant factors,
but I think that job where you decide
whether or not you pull the trigger and
end someone's life and you're a
panicker.
You know you're a panicker.
You're not a.
you're not a guy who does well in,
in confrontational situations.
Maybe you haven't been in a lot of
conflicts.
Maybe you've seen too much shit.
Maybe seen too many people get shot.
Maybe you're suffering from PTSD.
Maybe you're on edge all the time.
Maybe you have nightmares that someone's
going to take you out and then all
sudden you're in the hallway and this
lady comes out or an alleyway and shoot
her and you're like,
what the fuck?
Like you.
You might not even saw her.
You know,
people have hallucinations under great
duress,
like when they think their life is on
the line,
they see things that aren't really
there.
It happens to people all the time.
They'll,
they'll mistake someone for something
else.
The mistake someone for an attacker.
I mean,
that's fucking insane.
I mean she called the cops crazy.
That's what's fucking insane to call
nine one one because she heard what she
thought was a woman being assaulted and
then approach a cop car
and they get fucking shot phrasing.
I mean like what?
But it's what it is,
is people not handling pressure very
well.
Pressure is,
it's.
It is such a massive factor in the way
people behave and there's no bigger
pressure than you showing up.
You have bright shiny lights.
You're in the enemy car.
Okay.
You were in the NMP enemy uniform and
they know you have a gun.
And how many of them have watched so
many videos on tv of cops planting
evidence on Youtube of cops planting
evidence of kids being shot by cops and
stores were cops got shot in the back.
I mean like crazy shit.
So you're dealing with the weight of
that when you step out of your car.
Yeah,
I mean that's the anxiety.
Twenty four slash seven.
That's a job that is insanely hard to do
and we should,
we should figure out a way to reengineer
that position.
We should figure out a way to give them
more help,
more support and explain like,
like the,
the only way like cops and civilians are
going to get along is if there's no fuck
ups or very,
very few fuck ups.
Like anytime something like this
happens,
you realize you got to realize like you
got a bad system.
Like the system is.
You can't have just a regular person and
give them a gun kind of psychological
training.
Do they have.
Have you seen what they're.
What they're like,
how did they get the Gig?
If you seen what they're like under the
gun.
Have you seen what they're like when
someone wants to beat their ass?
someone is throwing punches at him,
trying to kill them?
Some guy randomly,
right?
He answers a call.
He opens a door,
guys throwing bombs at them.
How does he,
what does he do?
How does he handle this?
Does he shoot the guy?
Does he run away?
Can you fight back?
Has He ever been punched?
Right.
Fuck man.
You're asking some regular person to
just be involved in it potential like
civilian warzone on any given day,
like if you're in Miami,
Florida and someone gunshots fired in a
warehouse.
So like,
what are the odds?
These guys don't have like piles of
cocaine in his warehouse machine.
I've seen narchos come on,
man.
Well that's the thing.
It's like you've never seen a mellow cop
movie.
There was no like,
chill movie where it's like,
alright,
yeah,
you got a speeding ticket and then did
today and then the end is fucking nuts
except smoking the bandit.
It's pretty proven.
Then they drove recklessly.
Do nobody around.
Yeah,
I mean nobody to hit.
Right.
I have a question for you.
Okay.
What is this I hear about,
um,
your dream pills?
The pills.
Somebody said that you approached your
Alpha brain.
It's a nootropic what it is,
it's actually nutrients that are
building blocks for human
neurotransmitters,
like certain foods that are called,
or I'm saying foods because you eat
them.
It's their supplements,
mostly vitamins and minerals and a bunch
of different things that you can get
from plants and there's a series of
different kinds of nootropics and if
you've never looked into it,
it's a cool thing to study.
There's actually supplements out there
that enhance
your memory and they enhance your
reaction time as well,
like,
well,
you know,
how you feel like if you're hung over or
you wouldn't even understand what this
is,
such a man of health never drank,
but that feeling where you're like kind
of foggy,
like cut or some days you just kind of.
It's not firing,
right?
So we know for sure this is really
obvious to everybody that there's a
difference in your performance based on
a variety of factors,
right?
Right.
Lack of sleep,
nutrition,
exercise,
stress.
There's a whole host of factors that
affect how your brain forms nootropics.
What they can do is boost up your
brain's ability to remember things like
verbal memory is a big one that they
show.
And we did two double blind placebo
controlled studies about Alpha brain.
That's one of the things we found.
We found,
um,
memory reaction time and peak alpha flow
state all improvements and all like
statistically significant improvements
in those areas.
So what I've found is a,
uh,
there was a company called neuro.
One is the supplement.
I forget his company,
but it's Bill Roman,
you know bill very well.
Yeah.
That guy is Jesus.
John Savage,
savage as a football player,
super savage.
And remember we're going to talk about
the new cte study that just came out.
It's crazy with football players,
but anyway,
Bill Roman [inaudible],
he used to be friends with this dude
Sarah and no name and no name was,
uh,
that were cool radio station in San
Francisco.
Still love doing them and I'm no name
was friends with Roman asking
romanesque.
He was training him.
He was like,
he was like trying to get him in shape.
It's like,
come on you fuck,
I'm going to work you out.
And you put them through a bunch of
brutal workouts.
And then he gave him some of his
supplement and that's how I found out
about it.
And to supplement neuro one he invented
because he was suffering from head
injuries because he had been so many
concussions,
man,
he's having memory problems and all
sorts of issues.
So he started looking into um,
nutritional cures like what,
what helps boost neurotransmitters,
which helps boost serotonin.
There's,
there's like five htp is a big one that
helps boost serotonin and l trip to fan
as well because El Tryptofan actually
converts to a five htp and then you have
to add in a bunch of other shit like
adaptogens and b vitamins and all these
different things.
Like there's a combination that you can
hit of,
of nutrients and Bill Romanowski uses.
I think he used a little caffeine in his
as well.
Anything to do with him by the way.
This is not an advertisement.
We don't sell neuro one,
but it's the shit.
It's really good.
And that's,
that's the first thing I found out about
it,
found out about that.
And then we wound up making Alpha brain,
which is our version of it with a bunch
of things at work together
synergistically.
And um,
if you take that stuff before bedtime,
a lot of times you get freaky dreams.
Like if you take it like an hour before
bedtime,
like right.
It seems to like,
right when you go to sleep,
you know,
that's when it's just getting into your
system.
And I guess when you go into your rem
sleep,
you get an extra fucking fat,
juicy pipe of neurotransmitters to work
when you started having freaky ass
dream.
There's this full inception.
Yeah,
of a Paratha.
Tim is really good too.
People love that stuff.
Love that.
Coleen Coleen is a big one.
That's one of the ingredients,
the lucky charms.
I definitely am lucky charm.
They should be.
People will be like times made me very
smart today.
They're basically,
you know,
their nutrients.
Yeah.
No,
that's a trip.
I was just super skeptical about this.
And you definitely should be.
You definitely should be.
I would never ever in a million years
try to sell someone something that
doesn't work.
I would have zero desire and doing that.
So everything that we do it on it,
I use.
Yeah,
I use I or I believe in it.
It's like there's nothing.
There's no horseshit thing,
so when this whole new tropics thing
came out,
we like,
we rushed and Got Alpha brain out and a
lot of people call bullshit.
They're like,
they're like,
there's no studies.
No science is a snake oil.
I was like,
Oh,
you got to have like all your ducks in a
row.
You start claiming that you have
nutrient regardless of whatever
anecdotal evidence you have good
learning,
but I mean that's weird because people
never just cry bullshit over stuff for
no reason.
People never just go,
what?
No,
fuck that.
It's like everything that.
Everything that happens.
What I saw Katie Perry sitting down with
Deray Mckesson,
mckesson or Mac doesn't have a black
lives matter and Katy Perry was
apologizing about cultural appropriation
because I guess she wore braids for
whatever fucking reason and she was
sitting there is the weirdest thing
ever.
Man,
they're both on a couch and they have no
shoes on and she's touching him and he's
wearing a blue vest.
I was like,
what the fuck am I watching?
Was that in the dream or was that a real
look?
Look,
here's the thing,
dude wears that blue vest everywhere.
I mean,
he loves that blue vest that says,
look,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like Mr Rogers,
Mr Rogers,
first of all,
to get the socks.
I love socks.
Strong.
Confident man.
Are they in the Matrix?
Those socks are rainbows,
homie.
What bitch colors there?
And so she's culturally appropriating a
lesbian right now with her hair.
She should be careful.
She's culturally appropriating.
Literally an old lesbian.
She Re hipster an insane asylum that
there.
And that's her bathroom where she shits
that uh,
that picture on the wall.
It comes down and she climbs on top and
shits in the mouth.
Oh my,
uh,
yeah.
It's crazy.
It's a new thing.
All the celebrities are doing like,
look how they're sitting here facing
each other.
It's so bizarre.
I can't play any of this because I don't
want to get the video pulled off
youtube.
But uh,
it's mostly,
it's him sitting there listening to her
just go like this.
Coming out of her barfing,
she just didn't want people to be mad at
her for doing.
For wearing braids.
Yeah,
for for cultural outrage.
Let's see what she looked like when she
was culturally appropriate and cultural
appropriation is
so crazy.
The idea that you can't have braids if
you're white.
Oh my God.
Do people just trying to control people.
They're trying to control people whether
they're fucking two cents.
Everybody wants to throw in and chime
in.
Yeah.
It's just everywhere.
Everybody wants to be like,
oh no,
no,
no.
I got.
I have something to say.
It's like,
all right,
well,
and everybody wants to be able to be
mad.
They want to have a reason to get mad.
Yeah.
We talked about that earlier.
Everybody wants to be Super Superman.
Yeah.
We were talking about the behind the
scenes stuff at shows and about how many
different mindsets you have to kind of
manage when you're working on a show and
how many people were just looking.
You get outraged about stuff.
Especially lately.
It's so.
It's a weird fucking time for this.
Yeah.
No,
you cannot have choke.
I mean,
I,
I sent out like loose cannon tweets
sometimes,
then I would do it more back in the day
and then I just liked the more I,
you know,
you get shit faced and then like write a
tweet and I'm like,
I just,
I don't want to deal with what somehow
somebody could even.
I mean even like innocuous,
harmless instagrams and stuff,
people will still like jump on them and
be like,
Hey,
I saw this bird.
And they're like,
well what's the kind of bird is a,
well,
what did you fuck it?
Or I don't know what I mean.
Like,
well you hit it on the brim out.
I decided to it.
Don't you think though that for the most
part,
most of the interactions are pretty
nice.
There's just a snip of the most.
Yeah,
right.
There's a small but those small
percentage you don't forget.
No,
and it's,
it's just,
I mean it's the ones that are really
irrational and the ones that always make
me laugh for people,
it'll go like they'll comment or
something and I don't really read
comments like an uber on a plane or
something and I'll just like,
oh,
I'll see you check out the comments.
Some will be like,
hey,
fuck you,
you're a piece of shit.
I'm like,
all right,
like it.
And then they'll come back like,
can't believe you like that.
Like I was just kidding.
Like I'm a huge fan and I'm just like,
well this is just weird for me because
you're just sending it.
You just wrote a whole thing about hi,
I'm a piece of shit and I just liked it
and the night you're like,
Nah,
I just,
I just want to get you to respond.
Yeah.
From their perspective,
like that's the best way to get them to
respond.
Like that's the best way.
Like that way you know,
you'll,
you'll be,
you'll have your back up against the
wall.
Well,
it's like you said,
it's like when a lot of this stuff's
positive and then the ones that pop or
the people that are like,
hey,
you're fucking fist sucks.
You know what I mean?
That's so rude.
Which,
uh,
does your face does not suck.
It's dce dude,
you're fine.
This fifth.
Listen,
there's a lot of people out there with
some fucked up faces that would kill for
your face book.
But no,
I was saying about dreams I would have
like when I would detox from like a
fucking booze extravaganza and I went
out of dreams.
That's why I was intrigued because I
would have fucking crazy dreams where I
would be.
It would be so lucid.
I went here,
riders on the storm right now I can say
some stuff that was like a,
like a mixed version elevator on
mushrooms,
like Dj version.
So you detox detox.
I would have these dreams and there were
so loose.
I'd be like walking around the dream and
I'd be.
And I knew it.
No,
I was dreaming and I couldn't wake
myself up and I would try to wake myself
up.
So then I would try to like jump dive
out of a window to wake myself up or try
to like do something that will like jar
me awake and then I would do it and then
I would wake up and then I would be in
another fucking dream to not be in my
bedroom.
And I'd be like,
Oh,
I'm going to go up and get some water.
And then all of a sudden realize,
oh my God,
I'm still in the dream because this
isn't the shit on my walls.
And I'd have to wake myself up again.
Fucking gnarly dude.
Like you psyched yourself out in the
dream.
Wake up like,
Hey,
wake up.
Wake up.
Oh look,
you're awake.
Know who does really just more dream
your wicks.
Yeah.
So it.
So it was kind of fascinated by that.
It makes you wonder what is real.
If you could live in a perpetual dream,
what's going on there?
You still,
there's something happening.
You're experiencing things.
It's things are happening.
Whether you're lying there with your
eyes closed or not,
there's a bunch of shit that's going on.
A bunch of experiences that your senses
are taken in that are pretty fucking
remarkably similar to real life.
Right?
Like that's why it's so crazy because it
feels real.
Right.
That's why dreams like especially lucid
dreams trip you out because it feels
real.
It feels real.
But I liked it like when you dream like
a really weird dream,
you just accept the reality of like,
like when I remember a drag I'll be
like,
yeah,
I just totally was in the stream of just
accepted that I was like riding a
rabbit,
you know what I mean?
Like over a fucking skyscraper to like
Save Katy Perry's face or something.
You know,
we totally accept them.
Like what I'm doing.
Look at that fucking beard,
that Fabulous Morrison and people didn't
have beards back then either when he
had.
He grew this beard.
The video is him in a fucking beautiful
old mustang being a bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
Beards were like considered rogue back
then.
Oh yeah,
he was.
He was this rogue because it came,
man.
He used to post Dick on stage,
went to jail for it.
He's driving to the Tempe Improv right
there.
I remember that he was going to go see
joey.
How do we know
what really goes on when you're asleep
for eight hours?
How do we know when you're out cold?
When you call you're out,
right?
How the fuck do we know what's actually
happening?
What's going on in these this dream
states?
Because you only remember a fraction of
the time you're out,
right?
There's a fraction of the time would
have dreams aren't fake.
What if they're just some alternative
reality that you occasionally
intermingle with when you're conscious
or unconscious rather like when you go
into a dream state,
maybe that's just like the shadow of
something that just happened that was
real.
Maybe you have like these these moments
that seemed like eight hours to you or
five hours to you,
but you're really interfacing with some
completely different timeline and some
completely different reality and the
world is pliable.
It's not locked down like rocks aren't
rocks and water isn't water,
but everything's fluid and changing
constantly and that's why when you're in
these dreams,
you freak out because all of a sudden
like the physics of reality are gone to
Napa and do it.
Maybe there might be a war.
Look,
just the fact that this world exists in
the state that it exists in this world
is very,
very bizarre.
If it wasn't real like the.
This reality wasn't real.
If we all lived in some sort of a black
and white print version of life and then
you got to experience the life that you
and I know that students stand up and
being in La and flying and planes and
using the Internet and experiencing life
in the 21st century in 2017,
you would be like,
this is the craziest psychedelic trip.
If you went to Time Square,
you would never.
You'd never experienced anything like
human culture and you went to Time
Square.
You would be for wreaking the fuck out.
Yeah,
that'd be insane.
It would be insane.
We're just so used to it.
We're so used to it.
We don't realize how bizarre the actual
world is.
Well,
yeah,
I mean it's possible that these dream
worlds,
that these are just different worlds
that you tap into when you conk out
every night is a different world.
B could be infinite,
could be you're running a series of
lives like you have multiple lives going
on and your decisions you make in this
conscious life affect all of them and
maybe you have other lives when you're
asleep that are conscious when you're
awake,
but much like you're asleep and you
don't remember what the fuck is going on
when they're asleep,
they don't remember what the fuck is
going on and you interface.
You might not just be nick swardson
stand up comedian.
You might be an entity that interfaces
with multiple different dimensions in
the night and you just don't remember
it.
Just like you don't remember sleeping
right?
You don't remember dreaming.
You don't remember a lot of shit that
happens when you're conked out for eight
hours,
right?
Well,
they probably don't remember.
When you're awake and you're,
you're interfacing,
you're not just shutting off like your.
Your brain wants to.
Everything needs to shut off so that
your other self in this other dimension
can interact and can go about its its
world and maybe eight hours to it as a
month or a week to us,
we don't even fucking know.
Maybe that's a huge important part of
being a person is that other world has
to,
has to coincide with it.
Maybe that's why Michael Jackson died
because they gave him that shit that
knocked him out.
That didn't.
You don't dream under that shit.
They would basically put them under
anesthesia every night and he wouldn't
get to interface with the other world.
Alright.
I gotta go.
No,
you never know.
I'm fascinated.
I'm fascinated by dreams.
They fucking are weird man.
But I mean,
yeah,
the.
Maybe they do mean something.
Maybe there's another most likely not.
I mean I'm just covered in spiders and
screening.
I think that's basically.
Well you can let her roll your workout
stuff in your dream sometimes,
like you'll experience that workout
stuff,
but I don't.
I don't work out every names.
I never go to the gym and dreams.
That's a good.
I've never fucking
ever worked out and in a dream have
never done that either.
That's fucking crazy.
I used to throw kicks in my dreams.
I used to like when I was young,
but especially like girlfriends would
complain.
I would like twitch.
I would like literally like throw a
kick.
I remember when bill permit jokes about
it,
like sounded like a Bruce Bruce
springsteen song throwing kicks in the
night.
It was like an old ice house chronicles.
We went on a whole rant about it.
That's really interesting.
Springsteen,
a lot of guys have that problem.
Like fighters have that problem.
Dude,
my fucking old roommate in New York,
we couldn't wake him up.
You had to,
you had to like throw something at them
from across the room and then hide
because he.
Because he would wake up in an immediate
Malay.
It was immediately like game time and we
thought we found out the hard way.
We were like,
Hey,
wake up.
Then it was just thing they name and it
was just like he would just even take
him like fucking like 15 seconds to
like,
come back down.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
so I dunno what every day.
Alternate every fucking day.
What if an alarm clock woke him up?
He wakes up swinging or no,
that has be a person.
It would have to be a person's.
Why?
Just put an alarm clock next to him
will.
You couldn't afford it.
We were the alarm clock,
the bloody alarm clock.
Some people don't like to be woken up,
man and they get super mad at you and
the other people just chill like,
Hey,
what's up?
What's going on and why?
You guys waking me up.
Hey man,
where are you naked?
You ever seen someone get knocked out
and they ask questions.
They think like what's going on here?
So it's the weirdest thing.
Like what?
Where,
why are you guys here?
Like why are you guys staring out?
Right?
I've seen it before but I've never.
Not in front of me.
Dude,
it's weird.
It's weird to the brain,
the human brain when it gets shut off
and then comes back on.
It's almost like an old windows,
95 computer when it reboots and you see
the das thing right now you see the,
what is that,
that black with a white screen,
the boot screen does it dot the dos
screen and then it would take a long
time to boot up and it'd be all Janky
and shit and you wouldn't be able to
click on the Internet yet.
And it was like when you get claimed,
like I imagined football players,
it's the same thing,
but they oftentimes don't remember shit.
They don't remember anything that
happened.
They might not even remember like
getting into the ring.
They might not remember any of that.
I was gonna say.
I mean you've seen so many fighters go
through it.
Do they?
Do they ever remember the knockout?
Some of them do,
yeah.
Some of them remember everything.
They remember seeing like,
oh fuck.
Like that last moment where he's like,
he caught me.
Yeah.
And they're just out.
Yeah,
they remember getting hit.
They'll remember what hit them.
Some of them,
some of them don't remember anything.
That's the thing about brain damage.
It's a,
it gets completely variable.
It's variable,
like there's some guys that just,
they've been knocked out a ton of times
and they're okay.
It's weird.
Like Alistair overeem is a perfect
example.
He's been knocked out of gang of times
and he's fine like it.
At least he appears to be.
He's very lucid,
very articulate.
I mean he's a,
he's got his composure but after fights
he doesn't,
you know,
like when you get cracked,
like he got knocked out when he fought
steep Emile church and this is not his
fault and I said after this that I don't
think we should interview with fighters
anymore after they get knocked out
because he said that he thought that
Steve Bay tapped.
He thought he had the guillotine and
steepbank tapped.
Right.
So he was saying that in the replay.
So we had to play the replay back
because we didn't know if he was right.
I'm like,
we'll play it because he was saying this
to me while I was interviewing them.
That's why.
So we played it and you couldn't see the
tabby.
I think he believed it was just because
he just got knocked out.
Yeah,
that's not a good idea to interview
people after they get knocked out.
Terrible idea.
Terrible.
And I've thought it before,
but I never,
I really,
you know,
I just felt a felt bad,
like I had to play the video because he
said that it happened.
So if he said that it happened,
my job as an interviewer is to play that
video.
I just expected him to say something
along the lines of,
you know,
I thought I had um,
if you could remember the fight,
I thought I had him,
but he got them.
He got me fair play to him,
you know,
the normal stuff.
Give them a chance to represent
themselves.
So when that was going on I was like,
okay,
this is not fair.
This is like,
he's,
he just got knocked out cold and there's
no way,
like three minutes later.
Yeah,
no way.
No Way.
And then everybody gets mad at them for
that.
You know,
you can't get mad at someone for that.
It's too weird.
Yeah.
So this study came out today.
I'm Brendan Schaub.
Send it to me because he's freaking out.
It said that.
What is it?
Something like 97 percent.
Okay.
That they examined 111 former NFL
players.
Only one didn't have cte.
Wow.
Not only that,
they found that 87 percent of people who
play football at any level had cte.
This is what's really crazy.
Men who played football at all levels,
all levels for like.
So I,
I assume that's got to mean like high
school,
including high school.
Well,
yeah.
And who is that guy?
Jamie.
We talked about this before.
Forgive me for not a football fan.
I liked football,
but just don't know enough about it.
Who is that guy that jumped on the car?
Chris Henry was his name.
Yeah.
That guy was young and like a super stud
athlete.
Right.
I'd have been like 25,
26,
something like that.
When they did an autopsy on him,
they found out he had severe.
CTE was like,
this guy's brain is wrecked like pole.
See if you could pull that study up
because people were super shocked
because he was in his prime.
Yeah,
I mean he was in his prime and he was a
super athlete.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I mean you,
Jamie,
you know a lot about football.
What or how much of a bad ass was he a
as far as like top wide receivers.
It wasn't maybe like in the top 10,
but yes,
he was.
No,
he was starting.
He was starting to get to come into his
own man.
He died in a traffic accident,
had chronic traumatic encephalopathy,
Pathi.
I always fucked that up.
And cephalopathy and sap and sap and
Cephalon hmm.
That's a sense of apathy and Sepa
Apathy,
right?
Pathi and SEFA law and cephalopathy and
cephalopathy.
Boom.
Oh my God.
It's got to be neurosurgeons going crazy
right now.
Shut the fuck up.
You idiot.
You can't even pronounce a word.
A form of degenerative brain damage
caused by multiple hits to the head at
the time of his death.
According to the scientist had brain
injury research center,
a research center affiliated with West
Virginia University.
The guy says in quotes,
we would have been very happy if the
results have been negative,
but multiple areas of Chris Henry's
brain showed cte and then they go into
details about it.
So you gotta think like here's a guy
who's in his prime 28 years old,
right?
Just bad motherfucker and he's not
showing any signs of like falling apart
and he's got ce cte.
It's not scary.
Well,
I mean it makes you think too.
I mean I talked about that.
A lot of my friends is I'm a big nfl
dude,
diehard football fan and we were talking
the other day like does,
does it continue?
I mean like 25 years from now,
the rates for a lot of these guys.
Well,
yeah,
but I'm saying like does the NFL,
I mean,
oh I see what you're saying.
Does the NFL continue?
I mean at some point these studies and
these things are going to come out and
it's just gonna be,
you know,
it's horrifying.
Better off fighting.
I think you can get knocked out and
fighting and you definitely get brain
damage and fighting,
but I think if you become like a mighty
mouse,
like if you get to a skill level that
very few people get to when you were at
a super elite skill level,
I think you'd probably take less damage.
It's hard to say because there's been
some fucking wars with the mighty mouse
thing might be a bad example because
he's so fucking good.
A lot of his fights or just mismatches,
you know?
It's not like there's another mighty
mouse out there that's trying to fuck
him.
I'm like someone and not everyone can be
the mighty mouse,
you know what I'm saying?
Like it has to be.
There's going to be various levels of
competency across the board,
but like if you could fight the way that
guy fights,
like he doesn't.
He's not a brawler.
He's not doing anything stupid.
He's not just like biting on his
mouthpiece and throwing bombs.
He's super technical in his approach.
He's a consummate professional and like
a strategic wizard and how he approaches
interacting with guys who are almost
strategically wizard.
Although that was caught that though I'm
a wizard at all over your tents,
um,
but what he does is just the,
probably the safest way to do it,
the smartest way to do it because he's
just so competent it,
he's not getting hit and he's his,
his,
his tactics are so clever and so
skillful that he's able to like avoid a
lot of like big bombs that come his way.
Football players aren't avoiding shit.
Now you're getting hit getting hit.
You're getting hit.
Like there's no mighty mouse in the
football world,
right?
If you're a linebacker,
you're fucking hitting people or hitting
you.
You're hitting them.
If you're on the line,
you're not.
It's nonstop.
I mean to,
not just that he's not even getting hit
in the head.
They're saying doing this,
like slamming each other.
That stuff jerks your neck and your head
and all that stuff.
Just the sheer impact.
What are you going to sell the.
They just started this weekend.
This is like the pilot,
what they're calling the American flag
football leagues.
So there's like some former NFL players
in this.
Why don't they just blow guys on the
field yet?
I don't know if this is going to be
interesting to know.
Yeah,
that's football.
That was depressing.
Why'd you show that you can't have that?
No one that guy knows while he's doing
it.
The logo put on figure skating,
figure skating.
We need to get something more manly.
Rhythmic gymnastics.
I liked their helmets or lack thereof
though.
I like that.
I think that's very smart.
Um,
you know,
we just,
there's a rugby helmets.
Those are rugby helmets,
helmets,
the headgear.
There's more protect your ears and I'll
be going to help them if they had ground
maybe.
I guess maybe a little bit.
I would just wear ear muffs.
They used to have those things in.
When I competed in the taekwondo days,
that guy's got knocked out and one of
the real horrible things was that they
get kicked in the head knocked out.
They usually out cold and their head
would bounce off the ground.
So depending upon where the fight was
taking place,
most of the time there was no surface
like we would fight like on an actual
basketball court.
Like there's a video of me fighting on
an actual basketball court,
you can see the lines on the court,
it's solid wood,
and then you kick a guy and they'd fall
back in their head,
would bounce off the off the wood and it
was terrible.
Like some people got knocked out and it
was horrible.
So they started making.
People were first,
it was a head gear that you can just
wear on the back of your head literally
just to protect you when you get knocked
out so that your head didn't bounce off.
And then some guys,
they started making you.
Some guys voluntarily did it.
He started making you aware of the
bigger all-inclusive helmet.
So it's a big foam.
Protect it around your head,
like the you by football games,
like a foam?
No,
it's like a.
You can find it.
Pull up a taekwondo head gear.
It's like your face is exposed,
but like you have like these things to
cover your ears and the foam over the
protects him head Jerry later.
That's what it looks like.
That's exactly what it looks like.
There's an adidas one,
so it's like see how it's got the foam
around the ears and the foam on the top
of the head.
Your face is completely exposed and
most.
I don't know what that one is.
That's not a Friday the 13th.
The one you had on his.
Perfect.
That's a real tech window mass.
The white one or the Red One?
There's an adidas one.
Yeah.
So that's in those are world taekwondo
federation.
Once some of the International Taekwondo
Federation ones,
those tournaments,
a lot of them,
they did a differently and they did the
fucking stuck old school a lot of times.
I remember they still had the,
uh,
the wood floors and there was no head
gear.
They,
I think they probably change them as
time goes on,
but they,
um,
those,
those head gears were designed really
mostly to protect you when you got
knocked out from your head,
bounced off the ground.
Then they start making people find on
pads too.
After a while they changed the flooring.
I mean,
yeah,
heads is key.
Yeah.
It's fucking hard wood.
It's been the,
the being I found on the fucking meant a
hockey rink,
a hockey rink that didn't have any water
in it.
They put a tarp down like God,
they put a tarp down.
We fought on concrete.
It was horrible.
Why you put tarp down at that
point?
People get knocked out.
Two in one dude who got knocked out.
His eyebrow bounced off the,
uh,
off the concrete.
Like,
you know,
there was basically just like the,
whatever the bottom of a ice skating
rink would be.
You would drink.
It was for the bay state games too is a
big tournament.
It was a big deal because the bay state
games or the Olympic festival and it was
the first time and I think only time
they ever had taekwondo in it.
If I,
if I were going,
I was going to guess,
I think I was 19,
so it was like 86.
So,
uh,
these guys,
yeah.
There's one google taekwondo tournament,
kids on a hardwood floor.
Again,
see this might be,
it might be a tournament where they spar
or it might be a tournament where they.
Oh,
that looks like they have headgear on
the ground,
right?
They have,
they do,
they have forums turned out that little
red thing,
right?
Yeah.
Those are head gears.
What's the bar behind the.
I don't know what the fuck that is.
Like a float day for a pool.
I don't know what that is.
That might be,
um,
a different kind of tournament.
It might be a point tournament.
I think it's floating,
floating to new.
It's a new sport that comes to the Dildo
whipping.
So I was uh,
I was thinking about this this past
weekend.
I was talking to somebody about that
Brown bunny movie.
We've talked about that movie before
that said Vincent Gallo movie where then
he was a close 78.
Oh,
you said it perfect.
I've never said it right.
Ever.
I'm very good at trickle Joe.
Seven.
Yeah,
seven years.
Yeah.
And we're talking about how that fucked
his career for sure.
And probably fucked her career for a few
years too,
right?
Yeah.
I mean he was so promising to be a lead
Gargoyle,
but he was weird.
Freaky dude freaking fucking out there.
I mean,
like I had friends that were friends
with them years ago and they're like,
this dude's just on another planet,
you know what I mean?
Like,
of course.
I mean he got his Dick Sucked in a movie
for real and he got his dick sucked by a
movie star that's not just like getting
your Dick sucked.
I mean,
she's had a really good career though.
She's done a bunch of shit since then.
Yeah,
that was a while ago.
So she,
um,
I don't,
I'm out of the loop.
So what was,
what has she been in fuck?
She's one of those chicks it like pops
up and she was on an hbo show,
but she was on big love feel like I
remember a lot of good indie films,
but I feel like I remember there was
some bad ass to her in the beginning.
Am I wrong?
She was in kids.
Was there first thing?
Oh Wow.
She wasn't a movie called three needles.
That sounds hilarious.
Kids heavy.
Yeah.
Shattered glass is dope.
It's just in party monster.
Hold on a second.
Shit.
Jenny and the girl,
the main girl,
Jenny and forest gump.
Forrest gump.
Fucked her on camera.
I don't remember.
Kids.
I just remember it was a chick that got
eds.
I think so,
yeah.
Dude fucks her while she's asleep.
She's like,
don't want to change.
Just be casper and she's got aids and
the ideas.
She gave him aids
jokes on you.
Screen writers.
What was the or what was he telling you?
He was in the wire.
Everybody's said that I looked like him
when I was in high school.
I remember that.
I was like,
great.
Click on that.
And what year was that movie?
Boys don't cry.
American psycho.
She's done some shit dude.
Yeah,
but when did all that stuff happened?
Like when did the Brown bunny movie
happen?
No,
you just back up.
It was right there.
Go back the list bro.
Right up there.
Yeah,
there it is.
Okay,
so you got an academy award winning
movie.
Boys don't cry.
Yeah.
Then she's like,
time to fuck.
No,
it looks like time to fuck was before
that.
No,
no Brown bunny.
It's fucking after boys don't cry.
That's down now it's,
it goes lower.
I'm going the wrong way.
I was thinking the top was the more
recent ones.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a crazy choice.
So she's still done a bunch of stuff
since Brown bunny.
She did Zodiac.
I mean she was willing to be on big
love,
but not an agent must be so confused.
What do you want to do?
He had a real.
He had a real backlash.
Vincent Gallo,
didn't he?
I mean I think he's one of those like
self imploding dudes.
I don't think he was ever really like.
He did Buffalo,
66,
which is actually a cool movie.
She,
she never stopped working.
So you go 2003,
killing it.
Yeah.
So it didn't impact her negatively.
Maybe did.
I don't know,
but she still worked.
But you don't really hear about that
dude anymore.
And before that movie he was like a.
He was a big.
He was in Buffalo,
66.
Remember that?
Yeah.
That's a great fucking movie.
It just said that.
Joe,
did you say that?
Are you in?
So sorry you're in a dream state.
I was trying to remember.
I was trying to remember what we were
just talking about.
Yeah.
Buffalo 66 is cool.
Him and reach.
You did.
I didn't hear you say that.
I feel embarrassed.
I wasn't listening to him pray for the
cardinal sin of conversation.
I was just struggling with my memory.
It's ironically enough after telling you
about nootropics.
Yeah,
my four helmet now.
I did yoga today.
I drained my brain.
I'm a 15 percent stupider when I do
yoga.
I want to get back and doing yoga 15
percent stupid or in what way?
For like four or five hours.
Just wrecked.
Yeah.
Hot Yoga like my brain could God my
brain cooks.
I did that once and then uh,
I was like,
I'll try it.
My sister talked me into it and I was 15
minutes into it and I thought we were
done and I was like,
all right.
And then I got up and I'm like,
we have to be done.
And the woman was like,
no,
we have like another 45 minutes.
I'm like,
well,
you fucking do.
Like,
I,
like,
I just got out of there.
It was so intense.
I had done yoga a couple times,
I gotten cocky and it was,
you know,
I really liked yoga,
like kind of center me and show me the
fuck out,
you know,
and then I tried the hot shit and it was
just not cool man.
It was too intense.
It's intense.
Like you definitely,
I was dizzy and.
But you know what it is dude,
it's not the best if you have to use
your brain
right afterwards for like really solid,
like three or four hours,
but it is really good in terms of like
overall,
like the overall,
the overall your health and the way you
interface with the world.
Way more chilled out if you do it a lot.
Yeah.
But Shit.
So you did it and then just immediately
got in your car and then drove away.
What else do I do?
Stay tent up plot of land.
Lump.
I should go up in that area.
Yeah.
I took a shower and got the fuck out of
there.
Got something to eat.
Dinner,
shower.
I did of course got to sweat.
I think there's something really good
for your body though that especially
that hot one.
I think that 104 degrees and stretching
out,
I just think it makes you more pliable.
Definitely makes you more flexible.
Like when you're doing it,
you can get into positions that you
can't get into when you're cold.
So that means to me like there's some,
there's some sort of a benefit in being
like really warm in terms of pliability.
The muscle tissue.
Yeah,
a hundred percent,
a hundred percent that settlement
questions.
I mean it wouldn't be that popular if it
weren't,
it didn't have some kind of effect.
Yeah.
Even like,
you know,
it's like even like getting in any
situation when you're cold and
stretching or trying to do anything
active at the sucks.
Sucks.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
You can't,
you don't perform at your best when it's
80 below zero outside.
Yeah.
Like I get a massage the other day and
it was freezing in the air conditioning
on and I stopped the guy and I'm like,
what the fuck you doing?
Man?
Was like,
what?
Oh,
did you try to get some?
No,
no,
but I was like,
what the fuck man,
like turn this off.
A friend of mine,
his girlfriend was a misuse at one of
those uh,
Burke Williams places or something like
that,
you know,
might not have been that place,
but it was like a high end spa place and
they had a deal that one of them dudes
go because he had a,
he was running a whole prostitution ring
in there where guys would come in
really.
And it was like a,
uh,
like a name brand place.
Yeah,
like a legit place.
And he just developed clientele that
knew that he would suck their Dick,
he'd give you a massage and suck your
Dick.
Like he just had the market cornered I
guess.
I guess it was when,
when he likes sucking Dick and uh,
he wanted to make some money for
massages.
So his books were Phil fucking are
saving up for that land.
That land is going to pay for itself,
that,
that land ain't gotta fuck itself.
Yeah.
So if I can just plug my show.
Typical Rick Season Two already
canceled.
I already told you that.
Yeah,
you told me that we were just speaking
of red glowing relationship with comedy
central.
At least they gave it a shot.
How long?
How many episodes did they do before it
canceled it?
We did two seasons of six episodes each
season.
You can still watch it,
but when it's not going further,
what is it a surprise to you that they
canceled it?
No,
no,
no.
That we had to show that we wanted to
do.
We wanted to bring you on to do
something that was called
Bro Sasson and it was about a guy who's
raised by an assassin and then he got
the assassin.
Dad feels bad that his son never had a
real life.
He just grew up in a sas environment,
that jungle,
so he sends them to college and becomes
the ultimate Frat dude,
but he moonlights as an assassin still,
but he's still a frat guy during the
day.
Oh God.
And that was me when I would sleep in
the bed,
in the or in the attic and then I would
be an assassin that like on the down low
at night,
but I was always too high or hung over
or too drunk and we wanted to you to be
one of the guys that would be a
recurring assassin.
Dude,
I'm in comedy central.
Bought it in the room that I wrote the
script.
Everybody.
It was like,
this is hilarious.
And they were like,
no.
And then just passed on it.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I was like,
alright,
cool,
good talk.
Then I rewrote it for free and they were
like,
yeah,
we still don't want to do it.
I'm like,
well why'd you buy it?
They're like,
I dunno.
I was like,
cool.
See you guys later.
Good Talk.
Hello Netflix.
So our heartbeat and executive.
Imagine some of the bad shows that come
their way.
They'd probably get so confused,
you know,
it's probably like bad cops,
like network executives,
like we get mad at them because they
fuck shows up or they put in their own
input.
Or can you imagine how many bad shows
come their way?
How many just terrible ones?
Think about the ones that are on the air
and they're thinking about getting their
job fired.
The show's going to get canceled.
People are gonna lose money.
They're going to be out of a job.
They won't be able to pay their
mortgage.
Like,
fuck,
there's all this pressure on them.
Fuck.
And they're like,
yeah,
we'll buy it.
We'll buy it.
Nick will have to show why I hate the
show.
I hated to.
Sorry Dude,
can I process like these people were on
adderall.
They're all tweaking their work.
They're working 10,
12 hours a day and adderall is a lot
like math.
If you don't know that folks.
One of the,
one of the key things with people they
do when they do math is their shit at
decision making.
Their decision making turns to shit
caught.
Two Headline Joe Rogan says,
all network executives are doing meth.
That's how the.
I wish that's how it works on that lane.
I have a buddy of mine who's a writer
and he told me everyone's on it.
I said,
really?
He goes,
yeah,
he goes,
I just know so many journalists are on
it.
So many writers are on it.
They're all on adderall.
Well especially,
I mean in Los Angeles,
just like in terms of what I've seen
socially out and about.
I mean,
Holy Shit,
every chick is on adderall.
It's like fucking nuts.
I've never.
I've done it once and I was just
shitfaced somebody gay man.
Of course I put in my mouth and then I
just,
I didn't really feel it,
but you know,
it kind of made me a little bit more
alert,
like Kinda cookie,
but it wasn't anything special.
But I have friends that they just,
they take it constantly.
Yeah,
it depends.
I'm sure on the dosage.
It depends on the person,
depends on how you can handle and maybe
you can maybe some people it's super
beneficial and they can actually handle
it.
I'm not saying it's not,
I'm just saying for sure there's some
abuse going on.
I know people that abused
certain things are made for a certain
purpose.
You know what I mean?
Like when you make a pill that helps
people like focus certain situation Ed
folks.
Yeah.
That sounds like you fucking take it
coachella with like a bottle of fucking
fireball.
That's not why anybody made it.
They weren't like,
yeah.
This is a pill that you take at a music
festival with fireball agreement along
floor
it again,
the youth gone wild skid row.
Yeah.
That's good road,
right?
Isn't it?
Yeah.
I try to karaoke skid row once I was a
fucking horrible mistake.
I try to a karaoke.
That song.
I will remember you yesterday and it
fucking goes on for like six minutes.
And I know Larry
sounds like crying blog.
It was horrible.
I drove by the hotel the other day where
Jamie Lane died.
Do you know Janie Lane?
The lead singer of warrant?
She's my
in the hotel right over in woodland
hills.
How'd he die?
Um,
vegetables.
Eat too many vegetables.
No Dude.
It was all salads in his house.
His place was filled to the wall with
salad.
Oh my God.
Fucked up man.
He got two healthy.
So healthy drink too much water.
You've heard of that?
People dying from drinking too much
water like Frat hazings and shit like
that.
One.
They have water chugging contest.
Super Bad folks do not do that.
You can get to a state where your body
literally can't process all the water
inside of it and you die.
You can fucking what I eat,
die drinking water.
How does it kill you?
It ruins your Oregon's portion.
I do not know.
We should find that answer.
You drown?
That's a good question.
Something happens.
Some sort of toxicity,
some,
some effect of the water toxicity.
Sound smart.
When you say toxicity,
it's a good word to throw in.
If you're in the middle of words.
We're dealing with a lot of issues and
you know the random toxicity of the
environment.
Comedy Central.
Are they going to keep going with this
is not happening without Ari,
is that the deals are going to keep it
on the Arrow season and that's it.
I don't know.
It was a fucking genius idea.
What to take him off that show?
Yeah,
so fucking weird.
It's genius.
What?
Pull them off of.
I wish we could talk about why it
happened.
We can't,
I wonder if we can know that he's got a
special on Netflix.
I have to ask for permission where the
store is ridiculous.
It's hard,
man.
Like I said,
hard being an executive,
hard being what we call a content
provider.
Nick,
I believe you're a content provider.
Got to provide with comedy central.
But I mean I'm just saying in general,
I don't think it's that hard.
If you have talent that is proven in
that you trust.
Like if I a network and you brought me a
show that would for me,
that would be a 90 percent chance that
would go to pilot for sure.
Is nicked become executive.
I'm figuring out my career was,
I was uh,
playing the odds before they weren't 90
slash 10.
It wasn't that good.
Was it like 50 slash 50?
So I liked the odd.
So do you think you could maybe do that?
My job for me?
Yeah,
for sure.
Yes.
I will sign up for corporate America
executive Bro.
Could you imagine if decided like,
I don't like to show us your pick and
I'm going to be one of you.
I have not thought about doing that
because I hear it.
I have so many friends.
We all,
we're all from the same talent pool of
comedians and writers and suffer like
everybody has stories where it's like,
guy,
I pitched this.
I'm like,
that's fucking hilarious.
So like,
yeah,
it's fucking.
They were like,
no,
I don't get it.
Well why don't you just start doing shit
on your own?
Because like you did with Simon Rex in
particular.
I feel like you guys could easily do
that on your own and put it on youtube
and I bet it wouldn't be giant.
We could.
I mean we're going to try to shop it
around to a couple of other networks and
why get involved with,
with other people?
Well,
because I already have established
contents.
We already have two seasons and it's
already there.
So we just need somebody to go like,
yeah,
we get it.
What do you own it?
Like you can bring it somewhere else.
Yeah,
because it's just through streaming,
which,
you know,
comedy central is obviously like cool
enough that to give us that and then all
the executives got fired.
So.
Because one well done not because
they're like,
what the fuck did you give him?
Jesus Christ,
you just going to check it away.
It's going to go on vacation.
Have you heard about his dreams?
He's a lucky man.
He's kind of crazy,
man.
Yeah,
You got to do it yourself.
You know,
it's not their fault.
Even.
It's like counting on them to know what
the fuck they're doing.
They know what the fuck they're dealing
with.
A really be a TV executive.
Who wants to do that?
How many people want to do that?
They might think they want to do it,
but once you realize like the stress
involved,
fuck all that man.
It doesn't seem that complicated though,
right?
I don't think so.
I mean if you have people that,
you know,
someone could bring you Seinfeld and
friends and you know,
the whatever name some other show brings
some big ass frazier,
some big ass sitcoms.
Cheers.
Perfect example.
And you look like a goddamn genius.
He's the guy that got chairs in the air.
Whoa.
But you could've just got lucky.
They could have brought you the fucking
sex in the city or the single guy or a
lot of sitcoms and everybody forgot.
They could have brought you a lot of
bulk toilet.
The musical.
There was a lot of Bads,
coach,
you know,
remember coach like coach the fuck up.
Fuck is wrong with you man.
My bad,
bad experience.
Well that's you.
That's don't put that on coach.
The guy who was a writer for that show
on a Sitcom I did.
It was like whoa.
He just acted up,
backed it up.
Just swing.
And with the old double edge,
broadsword chop shop
I would say.
But that's a different conversation.
Have a network,
major neck and like in one of those
main,
like NBC,
CBS,
like that's so arbitrary on what's going
to be a hit.
Yeah.
But what they bring you like is your.
I mean
obviously I'm come the town pool of
talented people.
Yeah,
for sure.
But even talented people occasionally
create turds
of course.
Right.
So if you're a crap shoot,
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying there's different levels of
like what could you know,
what's got a better chance?
Like if you bring something with a
vision and it's really,
you know,
like you're,
you're passionate about it.
I would go,
okay,
joe is bringing me this impassioned idea
that I think is funny.
I'll give them a pilot.
That's the thing is about
shows.
This is a really hard part about shows
you're developing,
you're developing them while you're
presenting them.
So like the show starts out,
it's a new show.
You're trying to develop the characters,
you develop,
the way they interact each other while
you're putting it on the air,
like you creating any,
putting on the air.
Like as time goes on,
things get like you saw like Seinfeld,
like in the later years or friends.
A perfect example.
Everybody knew the characters.
Everybody just flowed together.
You knew even though there were a new
scripts,
like the thing was so established,
like what was funny about it and how it
worked.
When you're creating a new shell,
they're always like fire and peeling
that Kevin James Show.
Like they're,
they're like,
they change out the swap out the wife,
like they did it on bewitched.
Get her out and bring a new one in and
you need a black neighbor and be like,
okay,
you need a gay friend.
And then like,
you know when,
when it's not working,
everybody wants to throw their fucking
ges into the soup mix.
Like I know the perfect thing this is
missing and that's what happens with
those shows.
Right?
They all just get looped.
They just get all these different
opinions until they take out like South
Park,
they don't listen to shit.
They'll listen to anything.
But that's my point is that if you
comment,
major networks is different.
Like the cable networks,
they have a little bit more leeway where
it's like,
you know,
if somebody comes in with,
if,
if talent comes in with a strong idea
and a strong script and a strong vision
and stuff like that,
I think that's different with networks
you're getting,
you know,
a bunch of major show runners with an
idea and you know,
they're trying to fit into a formula
that's different.
It's still hard.
It's still hard,
but it's,
I'm just saying there's different
percentages of it.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
I mean,
South Park came in and they were like,
I remember stories where they were like,
they didn't get any notes.
They were like,
they don't even live here.
I don't think.
I think they live in Colorado or
something.
They were just like,
yeah,
well we're gonna make this show and just
like,
stay the fuck away.
That's probably a good move from
evergreen.
It was like one of my favorite places
ever.
Did you ever see the
original one?
What would Brian Boitano do?
Yeah,
of course.
That is,
that's how they got started and that is
to this day,
like one of the funniest fucking thing
I've ever seen in my life.
When someone gave him,
he was actually a girl I was dating.
She was an agent's assistant and she got
a vhs copy of it and she,
uh,
she brought it over my house and we
watched together.
We were fucking crying,
just falling on the ground crying.
He was so silly.
And Jesus versus Santa.
Yeah.
That was insane.
I didn't say thing.
I got the vhs tape in like 1996.
I'm to say.
That's exactly what it,
that's the time somewhere around there.
And I had that vhs and I would watch it.
I was like,
what?
This is insane.
It was amazing.
So,
and
it's kind of funny because it's much
more shitty animation and drawing even
in the current one,
which is crazy hard to believe,
you know,
you watch it.
It's like you're watching like ancient,
like ancient cave art of Jesus or
something.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
it's weird when you're seeing this old
way they used to draw everybody in
comparisons to the new voices are so
good.
Oh,
he's amazing.
Yeah,
they're genius.
Those guys are amazing.
Trey Parker did the voice in this new,
um,
what was the fucking animated show that
I watched?
He did the voice of someone then to
despicable me and that's what it is.
Despicable me realize.
Yeah.
I saw it with my kids.
It's hilarious.
Those despicable me.
Really good.
Even if you're in a full grown adult,
they are fucking fun movies.
My kids love them,
but I actually love them.
They're fun.
Those movies are good,
man.
You saw the third one,
I saw them all.
I've seen the first two have kids,
Bro.
I seen him multiple times.
Hold her kids.
I saw underwear,
man.
Oh yeah.
Captain underpants or something like
that.
And if they want underwear,
man show called captain underpants.
Yeah,
as a they made a movie out of it.
I'm probably not going to see that by
myself.
That'd be super weird because some guys
just watching captain and they make good
fucking kids movies today.
Those despicable me movies are good
movies.
Yeah,
they're really.
Well.
The third one holds up.
Third One holds up.
My bistronic is one.
A lot of people don't like the minions.
One of those little fuckers like they
need.
The other guy grew to balance out
demands.
Yeah.
You can't just have the minions.
Minions went rogue because it's just all
these fucking assholes.
People didn't like it.
I found it.
I think it was good.
I enjoyed it.
I found it entertaining.
Fuck them.
Fuck them Indians.
Well,
like toy story,
toy story three.
It was like one of the best movies I've
ever seen.
I started crying.
Yeah,
it was good.
I wept.
Yeah.
There were some dark moments when the
teddy bears trying to fucking throw them
into the incinerator.
That was intense.
Intense Shit.
Lots of air.
Lots of.
Have you ever see babe the pep talking
pig moving.
Did you ever see babe pig in the city?
Part Two?
I don't think I see that movie.
They decided to take the talking pig,
like broad farm movie.
Throw them in the city where some of the
dogs are prostitutes.
It goes so fucking rogue.
It's amazing.
You'll love it.
I'll text you and remind you.
Oh my God.
A pig in the city and there was a big
outrage because it was so like
aggressive and weirdly.
It's super dark and trippy.
Whoa.
Big P there.
Prostitute dogs.
I swear to God.
That's one of the hooker dogs and the
pink.
That is hilarious.
Got that Harlot.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Weirder dogs,
man.
They used to be wolves.
They scare the shit out of me.
I figured out a way to turn them into
that and have them live with us.
I think about that when I'm around my
dog because my.
I got a new dog recently,
seven months old
now.
I got him a few months back and he's a
golden retriever.
Okay.
It is the least wolf like dog that has
ever existed on the planet.
This dog has like zero aggression in
him.
Like even when he play fights,
like play,
fight with another dog,
just like zero threat of anybody getting
hurt.
It's like there's the,
the mellowest comments and you gotta
think like somehow or another people
figured out how to take a wolf and
slowly whittle it down until you make
that.
Right.
Like what?
What was he eating?
They probably gave him some weird
fucking shit and messed with his brain
denial.
It's just breeding.
They figured out a way where,
I mean,
I think that life is crazy pliable and
where you have the best chance of
success.
I mean,
obviously this is not my theory,
but where life has the best chance of
success,
it kind of molds itself to that.
Whether it's by putting people in colder
climates,
making their skin lighter so they get
more vitamin D because there's no sun
out.
So you're saying it's atmosphere
related.
Could be,
yeah,
and the atmosphere of a dog is the only
way that dog got food.
It had to be super cool with people,
so the dogs that were cool with people
are the ones that stuck around and they
kept breeding and breeding and the ones
that are the coolest with the people,
the ones who got fed and the other one's
got shot and killed and he didn't get to
breed,
so it's always like the ones that are
the coolest with the people that got
closer and closer to the campfire and
they get the scraps thrown their way.
It was a sweet deal.
You Bark and they.
They're cool with you and they give you
free food and you keep the fucking
wolves and the bears from eating them
and you bark,
bark,
bark when anything comes and they can be
alert.
That was the whole deal with people and
wolves and dogs and so they figured out
a way over countless generations to turn
that wolf into this fucking dog like
into a poodle.
Like they figured out how to do that and
it's just life adapts.
It.
Find some weird ways through and next
thing you know you're holding a French
bulldog.
Like what the fuck?
That used to be a wolf.
A wolf got whittled down to.
I'm not.
No disrespect to French bulldogs.
They're adorable.
I love those little dogs,
but it's like,
how the fuck did that even happen?
Yeah.
You never see like stone,
like cave drawings.
The poodles that didn't exist.
It literally couldn't exist with perfect
pum pum,
like ankles and shit.
You know what they found out about dogs,
it's really fucked up,
is that all of them came from wolves.
They thought there was like that.
Like dogs came from like a bunch of
different wild canids,
you know,
a bunch of different like African dogs
and different dog.
Nope.
All of them came from wolves.
All of them.
That's super weird,
dude.
Well then a wolf like fucked a frog or
something because there's no way a
fucking bulldog just comes from a wolf.
It does.
Slowly but surely over thousands of
years,
they turn a wolf into a bulldog.
Nuts.
Are we going to go back to wolves?
Do you think we could turn into Jello
for sure.
We could turn into some cube like thing
that sits in a hard form that we carry
around.
If people found out human and you can't
break your bones if you don't have any,
you can move things telekinetically now
and everyone's going to fit into this
fucking cube and we
just would be this square thing with no
bones.
Just slops right into this just
indestructable plastic barrier that you
carry around in life until you wanted to
fuck.
And then when you wanted to fuck,
you guys would get close to the bed and
then you would just ooze out on top of
each other.
You would like open your doors together
and just ooze on top of each other.
That's my entire family in Arkansas that
you just described to that zip pills.
It's everything else.
Got Them skittles.
I don't try.
Dogs scare me because the dog bit my
balls.
When I was a kid,
I was playing with a ball in my front
yard and I'll never forget it and I
rounded third and a dog lashed out and
punctured my scrotum and I ran into the
house and I pulled my pants down and my
mom started screaming and I just sit,
so dogs have always to this day,
every time I walk past the dog,
I'm horrified,
dude,
Dude.
Yeah,
not cool.
That ain't cool.
Maybe I won't be Jello Guy.
Yeah,
for sure.
No worry about it's better path and
getting bitten then nuts by a dog.
Yeah.
If you have no Oregon's okay.
Nothing can break down.
You're just a giant hive of tissue and
everything now is a dream,
but it's a dream that you can control.
They've gotten to the point where you
don't need a physical structure.
You don't need skulls and Oregon's and
livers,
all that stuff is handled exogenously.
They bring in things.
They bring in like these connections,
these tubes that link up to you and then
slowly our bodies devolved to the point.
We don't have Oregon's anymore.
We rely on all our organ functions to be
handled outside of the body by machines
because it's way more efficient and
allows you to stay in the dream state
and control your life.
Do you have eyes?
No,
dude.
There's no need.
You see way better and the dream state,
you have a mass of cells that somehow or
another contains consciousness that
interfaces with the dream state.
Twenty four slash seven.
Can I wear a hat?
You can,
but it doesn't matter.
You don't have a head like a hat on the
table.
That'd be a Jello shot.
You can,
but you know,
not a lot of juice there.
You want to be a big fat tube,
like a garbage dumpster filled with
cells.
The more cells,
maybe you have the more horsepower in
the dream dimension,
right?
That's how to make sense,
Obviously what we're definitely
devolving,
right?
If you go from like if you look at other
primates,
like primitive primates and you'll get a
rang of tens and gorillas and they would
fuck us up.
We're so weak compared to them.
Right?
So if you were obviously like the
weakest by far of all the primates,
other than like little tiny monkeys.
Yeah,
for sure.
So by far our bodies have gotten weaker
and dozier and less capable and like our
tendons are not the same.
They are so much stronger than us.
So there's something that's happening to
our body was getting smolder and softer
and weaker and they've a plant based
diet,
just even gorillas,
chimps eat the fuck out of everything
though.
They eat it,
they're more closer to us.
They're horrifying.
That story about
the guy who brought his chimp birthday
cake and the monkey attacked him and
then bit his nose off his fingers and
ripped his penis off.
Yeah,
bite his fingers off.
But it's fingers did his fingers up and
his nose.
You know the story?
Yeah.
The toward space apart.
He was jealous.
The chimp that attacked him was jealous
because he brought a birthday cake to a
chimp that used to be his.
See the chimp used to be his and he
would say the worst is that it?
Is that the story?
The chimp used to be his and he brought
the chimp to a sanctuary when it got
older,
because as they get older,
they get super sketchy.
They start biting people's fingers.
No,
they get super aggressive and the
consequences of them being aggressive or
so ferocious.
Don't,
don't show me any pictures,
please.
Andi want to see it,
so he had to give up the champion.
The chimp loved him still.
So you'd go visit him on his birthday.
He brought him a cake with the other
chimps,
saw the data and get a cake and someone
fucked up and left some doors open and
the chimps opened the doors and just
fucked him up because he didn't give him
a cake.
That's all it was because he didn't give
him a cake.
They tore his fingers off the towards
Dickoff just because they didn't give
him a cake.
Was that the idea?
Was it because of the character?
Was it the fire?
No.
Fairness.
No,
no,
no.
It was a fairness issue.
They were jealous that he gave the cake
to the one champion.
They didn't get any cake and they were
fucking furious.
And you're also dealing with these
chimps that are contained in this
artificial environment that our freedom
and they want to lash out anyway,
and they directly associate people with
being their captors.
You know,
the people are the ones that keep them
in there.
The people,
the ones that feed on the people,
the ones that control them.
And then if they can get out and fuck
up,
the person doesn't give him a birthday
cake.
Yeah.
Feel like the worst aspects of people.
Magnified Times.
100.
Like you'd see it right in front of us.
Like,
yeah,
this is what we used to be.
This is how we got to 2017.
You have to be fucking ferocious.
You couldn't be like,
hey man,
I'm just here to be like one with the
animals.
Back in the days of like living with
Jaguars and shit.
You had to Russia,
you had to,
you had to literally.
Yeah,
it was live or die.
So when we think of like what we're
becoming,
we're obviously becoming more passive.
We're becoming more better able to deal
with,
uh,
interacting with each other,
without violence and that all that.
All that stuff makes us mushier all of
it.
Is this making more?
It's not even a week.
It's just like physically not,
not attuned to violence.
Right?
So for physically not attuned to vote,
why do we need all the strength?
Like why do you,
why do you need to be so fast?
If I was trying to kill you,
you don't.
You sit in a cubicle all day.
So everything just starts to just like a
bulldog their face.
Somehow they figured out to make the
face.
I'll flat or whole body's going to do
that,
man,
I'm going to just flatten out.
So,
uh,
and then our body's going to absorb the
bones.
Once we start like encasing ourselves
and we'd go back to the Jello.
Paypal.
Yeah.
You realize you don't even need food.
You work like a,
like a plant.
You have this,
this box that contains you and it uses
photosynthesis.
Fuel your cells don't like water and
shit.
Just like soil.
He needs some soil.
You're going to put some soil below.
You're going to be a plant.
You're going to go back to plants.
Fuck plants in the Matrix.
Like in a week now I'll take a while.
Alright,
good.
100 million years or so.
It will definitely be like some sort of
a gigantic organism connected to some,
probably some natural internet.
You know what they'll do with their
figure,
they'll get to a point where they're
like,
you know what,
this regular Internet is too unreliable.
We're constantly relying on these
cables.
I have a new idea.
Here's my new idea.
We are going to make an internet by
going into all these plants and
genetically engineering them and turning
them into Wifi towers.
So everything is a wifi tower and this
is the new Internet.
They're all connected with each other
and you through using a computer or a
cell phone or whatever,
you're interfacing with nature now.
You're no longer interfacing with some
artificial servers and the verizon,
you know,
a fucking throttling your data because
they don't like using Netflix.
No,
no,
no.
Now you're dealing with re-engineered
plants where plants are now the
distributors of information.
I can't Tevye Tevye Bro,
but it might be real.
I mean they know that plants talk to
each other.
There are a hundred percent certain of
the prince plants allocate resources.
They have this whole,
uh,
underlying,
like there's like a,
a whole,
almost like an internet of mycelium and
like fungus and all this different shit.
All their network of their root system
and everything that they communicate
with each other about what we don't
know.
We know that they do certain things like
plants here,
uh,
other plants getting eaten and they
changed their flavor profile and they
become toxic.
They have like a terrible toxic taste to
them.
Wet.
Yeah,
giraffes do that.
Not always.
It's works or not drops of eucalyptus
trees do that when drafts are eating
them and uh,
a bunch of different trees.
They've shown that when you,
not only can they,
this is the craziest study they did.
Not only is it not knowing for sure that
these plants are being eaten,
but if they hear it.
So they played recordings of like
crunching recordings of Caterpillar is
eating leaves and they've played it next
to these trees and the trees altered
their profile.
They started reading some sort of a
chemical that makes their leaves taste
terrible.
So what they found is like that,
like if it'll happen in Africa,
we're one plant will be thanks to the
Acacia tree.
That's what it is.
It is right.
I'm pretty sure things.
The occasional one that changes,
it's not eucalyptus is the Acacia tree
and one animal will be eating it.
The other animals catch wind that
something's eating it and they literally
become toxic to them.
They taste like shit and so they won't
eat it and they'll starve to death
rather than eat the plants some crazy
chemical strategy and they communicate
with each other.
That's how they find out that this other
plant is getting eaten.
It goes through the ground.
They have this fiber of Jesus.
It goes to the ground.
They have this fiber
of all these different organic things
like like fungus and mushrooms and shit.
They're communicating with the Lord.
It's amazing.
That is amazing to think that like they
just don't even hear it.
The allocate resources,
they're like figure out a way to
allocate resources towards plants that
are connected to them that are more
needy.
It's a very bizarre.
We totally don't know why they do it.
We taught me,
we don't know how they're doing,
it's all some new thing over the last 20
years that people are beginning to
figure out that these plants are somehow
or another interacting with each other
and maybe interacting with their
environment a way that we just don't
understand yet.
It's fucking weird,
man.
I mean they might be conscious and just
some way we just don't imagine we can't
imagine it.
Right.
But there might be some sort of,
uh,
you know,
we think of consciousness as like,
hey man,
I'm going to go to the store to do a
set,
you know,
hey man,
I'm going to go take my girl to the
movies.
That fucking planet of the apes thing
looks sweet,
you know,
that's what we think of as
consciousness.
Every day I do that.
But without language and whatever the
fuck plants use for communicating,
it might be some sort of a weird
language that they have the,
we don't even perceive.
But we could even have classified that
as language could be.
We don't know.
I mean,
I don't know.
I'm just guessing.
I'm talking shit while I'm hydro right
time asking questions because I just
want to figure out what to have a more
plant based diet,
but I don't want motherfuckers
whispering and shit.
Yeah.
Like donate careless whispers in your
cauliflower.
Mark somebody,
but maybe they like to eat them because
they didn't like it.
Eat them.
How come when you shit out there?
Seeds.
That's how plants get distributed.
Well,
yeah.
Also how do they know what tastes like
shit to us?
If they're altering how it tastes,
they're trying to get us to eat it and
it was just trying to make it better for
us to eat them.
Maybe they're like,
oh,
maybe oh he's eating mark.
Maybe I'll fucking create a new spice
and maybe it'll be better and he'll eat
me faster.
Some shit.
Hence peaches.
Why pizza so delicious to try and trick
you into eating them.
So you shit out one of those pits,
right?
If you get some nice nutritious shit,
especially if you've been eating nothing
but peaches,
your shit would probably be fucking
Primo for growing a peach.
Just ready for an s and m dungeon.
You're out there in the woods,
you take a massive dump with a bunch of
peach pits in it and they fertilized and
then a new peach tree grows and this
one's even better.
It talks to you in a deep,
slowly,
just like a wolf becoming a French
bulldog.
The peaches become sweeter and sweeter
and sweeter,
and then even we get in the mix like,
you know what,
this whole peach sweeten and shit just
seeing happening fast enough for me like
me and my boys Monsanto,
we brought scalpels and laser beams and
birth control pills and we're going to
figure out how to get these peaches.
Super Sweet.
And they last for a year,
right?
Yeah.
But what if you'd take a shit and the
tree grows and it's not pages and shit.
That's shit the shit.
And you can't hack that square.
That's what ends up happening.
The peaches get so sweet that they turn
into shit.
Yeah,
right.
You.
That's the world I want to live in.
It's like you fix it until you break it.
Exactly.
You fucked up.
You tried to sweet.
Try to get the peaches to sweet and he
got to the point of grady nature
rebelled.
Yeah,
so that's the argument for diseases,
right?
The reason why there's so many diseases
for human beings is that there's just
too many of us in nature's like,
no,
no.
You can't just do this.
You can't just have 7 billion of one
thing.
This is fucking stupid.
We've got to kill some of these things.
No,
we kind of figured out a way.
we got like plague and all these
different things.
We're like,
no,
no.
We got injections.
We're gonna.
Kill all that,
and then we're going to keep battling
it.
One step ahead.
Diseases and scientists are going to war
everyday on the front lines.
I mean,
that's what's going on,
dude.
Nature is trying to.
Jack,
you think they just trying to pull
their.
They're pulling the plug on us.
What was the last time you dog
sick?
I don't have a dog.
If you have a dog,
here's what you do.
You give your dog a Parvo shot.
They get distemper,
they get rabies and they're good.
They go around eating everything they
find licking,
licking everything,
pissing on everything.
What percentage of dogs get sick?
Is it even one was the dogs that get
cancer?
Right.
That can happen,
but like dogs getting cold weather.
When does your dog gets sick?
Your dog starts sneezing.
Dog.
Ever get it?
Hold the fuck Outta here at dogs.
Don't get my dogs.
I don't have a dog,
but if he did,
I mean I've never heard of a dog getting
it like a sinus infection.
They happen.
They happen when those bulldogs for sure
they get all fucked up because their
noses only like a half an inch long
where they have upper respiratory like
horrible problems.
I have friends that are bulldogs and
they said it's a fucking nightmare.
One of my dogs,
half bulldog.
He's half bull dog and half Shiba Inu.
So he's got like a little bit of a
longer face.
Watches that star wars character.
What is the sheep dog?
Okay,
son of a bitch.
You fucking made that up.
I didn't to country.
Little Furry dog.
That's a little on the aggressive side.
You know?
Get a little cunty.
Senior dogs,
half content,
half country,
half months.
Naps just wants a nap,
but he gets country with other dogs.
He bit my puppy in the face.
It's pretty cool.
So your dog?
No,
that's not my dog,
but my other dog,
the biggest dog a have is the most
chill.
He doesn't fuck with anybody.
What the fuck dog was that?
Oh,
I did not have eyeballs.
It did have eyeballs.
Do you need glasses?
Let's pull that picture up.
Oh,
look at that little cutie.
That's why I got him because he looked
like that when he was a baby.
That's what your dog looks like a little
bit.
Basically a little more bulldog to them.
Tell it her eyes.
But the thing about dogs,
man,
it's just stayed very so much.
Personality wise.
It's a trip.
You could have three dogs from the same
litter and one of them's just a totally
different kind of dog.
And the other ones,
like when they get dogs for police dog
training,
they never know like what dog's gonna,
like how they're going to come out.
Like you look for a specific type of
behavior,
but you don't know why he's like good
blood lines and everything like that.
But out of illiterate,
they're not 100 percent even in a good
bloodline,
but they're normally what kind of
police dogs are never.
Like,
there are specific,
like German shepherds are.
What are they?
Uh,
they have a bunch of different dogs.
They use Belgian malinois are really
good,
but those are super hard to control.
The golden doodle get attack dog.
They're real good attack dogs like the
second sick on people that like very
effective because they're super hyper
aggressive and they'll just go right for
your throat and fuck you up.
They use those a lot in military,
what they would call the military
theater.
Oh Hm.
I like that.
Is that what they say?
They'll say that military theater,
military theater.
And they said that starting closing at
seven and then it's like a way to sound
smarter than you really are.
If you said using something in the
military theater,
like what kind of an asshole says that
military at theater,
anything you sound like you're smart
with the diarrhea theater.
We're going to the.
Yeah.
If they like had musicals and they did
them in basketball courts,
they'd make $2.
Nobody go see a musical and a basketball
court.
You have to go to that.
Now I have to dress up and you can see
it.
How it really is.
Sneakers squeaking on.
Aluminum steps and these people have no
microphone and then below you doing
their stupid play.
Yeah,
that'd be shit.
Be like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Bitch theater.
Who it went to the um,
this new musical at the gymnasium.
It was terrible.
Everyone started throwing toilet paper
down on them.
You go to the theater,
you like this place is old.
This must roll.
I've got a new suit for the gym.
Yeah.
Nobody's ever said that.
Going to the theater.
Some of the theaters that you're
performing,
when you start performing in theaters
across the country,
you'll perform in a place.
It's like star.
It was founded in 19,
20 old.
Weird backstages you going to walk
through and everything.
It's fucking pretty dope.
Oh,
what I was going to say earlier as we
were talking about Florida and I did my
last tour and I did 55 cities.
Everything was great and there were only
the only train wreck shows where Florida
and uh,
I did a performance art center and it
was in,
I believe Orlando I'm going to say.
And I showed up and they had,
I went backstage and they have these
huge murals for wicked and the lion king
and all these huge productions.
And then there was nick swardson and so
I was like,
all right,
did this show me to stop the show?
Because to chick's got into a fistfight.
Oh,
of course.
Over what?
I have no idea.
It was in the balcony and I was like
trying to figure out what was happening,
but I couldn't because they were
escorted out.
And then afterwards they're like,
yeah,
it was a fight.
And then bunch of people,
there's vomit all over the bathrooms.
So that I went out to the staff and was
like,
what happened?
And all the staff were these old women
that were like used to plays and
musicals and weren't ready for the next
sorts and fucking tornado to come in.
So all
these,
like 80 year old women were not equipped
for like this,
that people are sleeping in the
bathroom.
There's puke on the floor.
Like that is hilarious.
It was pretty funny.
I was like,
yeah,
sorry about that.
Next week though,
we've got a next week.
It's a resurgence of cats being brought
back by.
Popular demand.
Is cats being played anywhere across the
country because I know it's not on
Broadway anymore.
I don't know actually asked that same
question.
It's not on Broadway at all.
That was a,
the,
I have a bad,
bad,
uh,
opinion of musicals and a lot of is
based on a girl that I dated when I was
18 who made me go to see cats with her
and what not.
And you're 18,
you don't have any fucking patience for
anything.
Well,
yeah.
What the fuck?
Definitely don't have any paid two years
old musical people that are dressing up.
It is playing somewhere.
Ooh.
Where's it playing on Broadway apparent.
Andrew Lloyd Webber's.
Long running classic is back on
Broadway.
Exclamation point.
I mean from Caroline's.
Remember?
Yeah.
I don't mean to diss it.
Last time I saw it was 30 fucking years
ago,
32 years ago almost.
Well,
there's still cats have not evolved.
I feel like I need to go now.
Let's go.
Go,
go.
Build lasted like seven stars of death
deep and we should eat first like hey,
take the stars of death,
like full on.
Take five stars of death and then have a
stake.
So this is my thought process.
You're sitting in a restaurant like
right after you order it,
you go,
all right,
let's do this.
You dumped this stars of death down your
system and then the food starts coming
so the food piles on your body has to
struggle to digest the star and all the
fat from your food like steak and mashed
potatoes.
If you're feeling non quito and as you
get it gets cooked.
And like,
right when these dudes like Doo Doo,
Doo Doo Doo Doo dee dee dee,
you,
you're just in a cyclone of fear and
self doubt and self criticism and
introspective thinking and feeling
vulnerable about everyone's watching you
and you know you're going to die and
everyone's going to die.
And uh,
and then,
and then to top it off though,
we bring a litter box and so we all
dedicated to the litter box and then
when they get mad at us for like,
it's fucking were around cats too.
This is perfect.
I was in Pittsburgh and uh,
I showed up for UFC in Pittsburgh at the
same time when they had a furry
convention.
Oh no way.
Just told you go.
I would've gone into,
couldn't had to work,
cancel the show.
I can't.
I had a show and then I had to use.
I like,
it was there for both shows and that had
the UFC way inside the way ends on
Friday.
And then I had the show right after.
I didn't want to go anyway.
I just,
I just want to,
like they were,
you could see enough by seeing them
interact in the streets,
but as you're driving down the street,
you would see fucking dozens and dozens
of people in these furry outfits.
Dozens.
I mean everywhere you looked,
you saw like these mascots,
like
squirrels,
fucking people that are dressed up like
monkeys.
Look at that.
Fox is and shit.
Then they fuck each other.
Yeah,
they do.
Well,
here's,
so you know that anybody wearing that is
fucking something.
Yeah.
And you know what you might like try to
fuck a female Fox and you pull down the
pants and it's a hairy dude,
but you know,
like,
well God damn it,
I'm already here.
I'm not really ready for this.
But like look how they're all walking
around and they get together of um,
there's photos of thousands of them
together.
Just thousands and people love it.
It's got to be so hot.
But do they physically hot?
Yeah,
like outfit.
I mean I've worn costumes like that just
said like sketches and shit.
Okay.
But what do you,
what is going on here in this picture?
This is so strange.
They're courting each other.
They're holding hands and staring into
juices,
eyes like,
you know what this is?
It's like you saw cartoons and your
little kid and they just fucked your
brain and be like,
well this is what I'm looking forward to
when I get out of this house.
Then you got out of the house,
you hear car accidents,
gunshots,
rape,
but do they fuck each other while
they're both wearing a costume or do
they fuck people that aren't wearing a
costume?
Apparently,
and this is it.
I'm sorry if you are a member of the
furry community and I misrepresent you,
but some of them have hatches were their
asshole is sort of like those old school
pajamas in those.
A wild west cartoons.
Remember the wild west pajamas where
they had like a.
like Popeye always had those dukie flap
and you've got two buttons that cover
your shit,
like the shit trap and you open up the
trap door and drop a bomb in there and
then button that fucker back up.
They didn't have.
They probably had draw strings.
They probably didn't even have like
rubber waistbands back then.
Right?
Like how it goes.
Big Buttons on either side.
How do they tighten down your underwear?
Back then it was buttons that makes
sense.
It's probably a buttons in the front.
Buttons in the Shitter who did buttons
on everything back then,
so these kids,
they thought that was the future and
then they went out there and they got
punched in the face.
The moment they left their house and
then probably somebody did terrible
things to them and they went to school
and they got picked on and then he had
are just wishing they were a squirrel
holistically.
It was horrible.
Just look in the cartoon.
That was my favorite thought when I was
young and what's this girl cartoon and
be like,
Oh,
you want to be a squirrel?
I didn't want to go to school.
Didn't want to do this anymore.
Just want to be a squirrel.
Will the hotel where we were at,
they got a request with.
They're filled up with furries except me
and a few of the other UFC staff.
I'm not.
I'm not lying.
It's filled and they got a request and
the request was the furies asked if they
could put a litter box in the lobby.
No Way.
Yes.
They wanted to pay for a litter box,
be brought into the lobby.
They liked this whole convention is all
us,
so can we do that?
And like.
I was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
They took my idea for cats.
They tried to get a litter box and put
it in the front lobby of like the
western in Pittsburgh to make smell.
Ian Apparently.
I mean it could have all just been just
good to be like,
come on man.
Well they definitely were asking for
food to be delivered in bowls on the
ground.
Whatever they ordered.
They wanted to put a bowl like a dog
food bowl and it on the ground.
Right.
It was several different rooms that were
requesting this that I can see though if
you're going to go that distance,
but if you're not taking a shit in the
fucking lobby,
right?
August,
you don't know until you ask.
I think it's all us.
It's all us here.
It's just all us.
We're amongst friends.
We'll pay.
We'll pay him.
Let me just ask.
Let's just ask like,
they're so crazy.
They just probably asked.
Yeah,
I mean I like have.
They'll just have a litter box in your
room.
In the lobby.
Yeah.
Come on,
man.
I've been a lot of them.
Had them in their room going up that
fucking flight of stairs with a Duffel
bag filled with litter housekeeping and
a big Ole fucking plastic cement mixer
for the kitty litter and one of those
plastic cement mixes.
You know,
ever make concrete.
When you were a kid.
Do you ever have to make concrete?
No.
Construction jobs.
Sometimes you'd have to make concrete so
you have to pour the shit and pour the
water and mix it.
You have to mix it.
And this big old fucking plastic tub
that was a lot like a big litter box and
you could just do that just to get one
of them.
Cement mix and tubs could.
Lord,
I want to do that.
I want to try it.
If you get thousands of people,
I would get into a furry outfit.
I don't want to get fucked,
but would you be.
Who would I be?
Yeah,
it could be a furry.
Like what creature would you?
Uh,
what do you feel like your spirit animal
is?
Nick?
It's a good question.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Do you think you're a monkey or wolf?
I would say a monkey over a wolf if
those are the options.
Okay.
So we're moving more towards monkey.
I'm just trying to get like a taste
palate.
It's a series of questions that I use to
determine which one will be best for
you.
Oh,
I would say a squirrel.
Squirrel.
Yeah.
Like you already midwest.
You are rat,
but your tail is so cute.
We let it slide.
Plus you only eat nuts and plants.
Yeah.
Rats eat everything.
Sketchy.
Yeah.
Rats or just can't be trusted carrying
diseases.
Squirrels are chill.
I used to hang out with girls in New
York.
I would go into a union square and I
wouldn't get up.
I saw a guy get a bag of nuts and I
watched him.
He would sit in the middle of the park
and the squirrels would come and crawl
on him and he would put the,
he would put a nut in his fist and the
squirrels would reach in like,
like it was like a little hole and pull
those out and eat it on his arm.
So I studied this guy for weeks and I
was like,
I don't want to fucking do that.
So I go and I get a bag of nuts and I
got the courage up and I got into the
middle of the park and I sat there and
the squirrels started coming on me and I
started getting panicky but you can't
panic.
So I zoned out and then the squirrels
started feeding out of my hands and I
started becoming squirrel man.
And then I started.
I wanted to show my friends.
So I bring my buddies and the like,
like to the park with me and I'm like,
watch this.
And they'd be like,
what the fuck are you doing now?
And I'm like,
watching this girls will be on my arms
and stuff.
And my friends were like,
dude,
I'm not on board with this.
Nobody thought it was cool.
It just thought I was like a fucking
complete lunatic.
And I saw it.
I was like this.
I thought it was like an x men or
something like that.
I had gotten this like power that I
dialed into like a whole.
I don't know.
He became like a beastmaster.
Yeah,
I thought it was rad.
But you remember that show?
Yeah,
of course.
The duties to be able to tell animals
what to do and they all listen to him.
That was the shit fucking ripped.
The one thing she could remake.
They fucking doubt.
That'd be a sweet remake.
I know 100 percent.
You should be the beastmaster.
You or me?
We could be beastmaster.
We could do it.
Brothers and sisters.
Beastmaster need a bunch of chicks to.
We gotta you gotTa have diversity today.
If you're going to pitch a show,
we should have at least one black female
trans beastmaster look at them.
That seems like the newer version of the
master.
Is that the original beastmaster?
I didn't know.
There's that guy right above that.
Yeah.
That was the original beastmaster dad
was the dude that was in a movie called
laserblast.
Laserblast was a fucking favorite
science fiction movie of mine when I was
a kid.
Man.
Like during the star wars days.
Yeah.
And he found his gun.
He found his gun on the right.
Oh,
so bad.
You put it was this alien gun that you
put in your arm,
like you put your arm in it rather like
you fist this gun,
I guess how it works.
And he found this thing like the alien
that's crashed their spaceship and lost
their gun and this dude picked it up and
the gun slowly but surely turned him
into this monster.
It was awesome fucking thing.
Yeah.
See that guy like see the pictures?
Those are the actual aliens.
That's what he turned into.
Those.
The laserblast 1978 dude.
Yeah.
It was 11 years old and this came out.
So when you see the guy like in the
upper pictures,
go scroll up,
scroll up a little bit,
see that like the one with the teeth out
and the left hand side.
And the top on the left hand side.
Yeah,
that one.
That,
that is what he turned into when he kept
fucking with that gun.
The more it was like sort of like a take
on columns ring in a way,
right?
Like the more he fucked with his gun,
like the more he would become like one
of those aliens and start shooting shit
with this weird fisting gun.
It was dope though,
Dude.
See if you can get a clip.
You find a clip online.
Turns into me in Vegas.
Hey Dude.
When you're 11,
it's awesome.
Cool screen.
It's a special preview.
Oh this is a preview.
See?
So dude,
find system.
The desert.
What the fuck can the aliens like?
Oh No.
He's got a gun.
They're pissed off.
See?
They're in their spaceship and he uses
it right now.
Somewhere on this.
Yeah.
See the spaceship lands and visitors to
the effect.
Oh my God is the greatest thing of all
time.
Shot them.
Fuck them up.
And they fucked him up.
Anything on this in the future?
Look it up.
He just looks like a Douche,
right?
Turned into a monster.
Look.
Tried to take it away,
ladies.
We have the new studio.
We should do a fight companion with this
movie laser blast wound.
You don't drink anymore?
I do.
You do?
I'm just taking a break.
How much of a break?
I'm sorry.
I started on the movie and like two
weeks,
so I'm taking a break until after Labor
Day.
After Labor Day you and I will get
fucked up and we'll watch laserblast 100
percent and we will start it from play.
Will Watch this fucking silly movie.
Play more of it.
Keep it.
Just keep it running in the background
the entire time.
This show's on.
Yeah,
it was like 10 seconds left of the
trailer.
So bad.
How bad is it?
That looks really bad.
I'm a gun.
Sounds like that.
Oh,
I was
wrong.
That's not.
That's not the laserblast guy.
It's a different grants and different.
It looks like he's from another movie
though.
The Guy,
the laser blast guy was in or the
beastmaster guy was in some other
movies.
He looks familiar.
He looks like an old of shit.
What is this a French for?
Not The whole movie.
They said,
well wait,
show beastmaster trailer,
how bad it is.
Look how bad.
Like even though like the fucking
letters or shaky like when they play the
letters because when they can't even
keep it,
no effort into the skill back then they
would like,
they would do all the shit by hand like
a bunch of monkeys.
That's a dude.
Kim Milford.
Cheryl Smith was probably hot as fuck
back in the day,
right?
She definitely did.
Coke,
do you think so?
I mean it was 1978.
I don't think they were.
Do.
I don't think you had a choice back
then?
Yeah,
they made you do coke.
They punched in your face after you when
you were born and you had to wear bell
bottoms.
This is the beginning of the movie.
Dude's like,
Hey,
what's that?
Like this movie?
So fucking stupid.
He's like,
well,
just walking through boiling hot shit
desert.
So I think this is like the alien with a
gun.
Well,
let's save it until we wait.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's what we watched and we'll save
it.
Yeah.
This is the original alien that he was
a.
that's what it was,
that that guy dies and leaves him the
gun boiler alert,
so I'm wrong.
I thought that that guy was the
beastmaster guy,
but beastmaster doesn't matter.
We were still turned onto a gem with
laser blast.
I'm glad I remembered that.
I don't how I remembered that.
I don't know how the fuck that's still
in my brain because I haven't seen that
movie and I probably haven't seen it
since like a year after I watched the
first sign,
that singer he was in,
he was in some movie,
played a blind guy.
That guy's been in everything.
Yeah.
He was a teen wolf.
Kissing a dude.
What's that all about?
Cut that out.
A beauty and the beast.
He's going Lrg on that.
Yeah,
he's in.
That guy's got a gang of movies.
He did,
but also peace master and the young and
the restless.
If you had a beastmaster,
would it.
Would people think it was racist?
If you hired a black guy,
what do you mean?
If you had a guy that could talk to
monkeys,
because obviously he's a white guy.
If it's a white guy in the white guy can
walk into the forest falcons land on
them and fucking drafts come up to him
and he gives him an apple and shit.
Everybody's cool with it.
But if you had a black guy like jet
black,
Wesley Snipes Black and he's walking
through the jungle and all the animals
flocked to him and he,
he had the monkeys,
they talk to each other.
He tells the monkeys what to do.
People will be like no fucking way.
That is so racist.
Are you saying that black people are
like closer to these animals to fuck?
No,
no,
no.
That's what we're saying.
No,
no,
no.
We're saying he's really cool and the
animals like,
that's not what I got out of it bro.
How come white people can't talk to
monkeys but black people can't get the
fuck out of here with your racist
bullshit ass ablest movie.
Right?
But,
but if it's a white blonde guy,
you're like,
yeah,
as soon as I can talk to anything,
it's amazing.
He's like channels.
The spirits with these animals.
They know he's pure.
Isn't official here supposed to a
Unicorn?
People would freak out.
He doesn't have any clothes on it,
but it's Harris quaffed.
He's like,
he doesn't need clothes,
bro.
I just need shampoo and conditioner.
He lives in the jungle,
but his hair is just perfect.
Fits just like styles,
a little kind of frosted lightly.
Somehow he is highlighted for the
forest.
Doesn't make any sense.
He's super close with the eagles.
Dude.
I had a hawk issue in my backyard
yesterday.
Um,
I tweeted.
I instagram is picture that I found a
hawk dead in my yard that another animal
had something had bitten.
It's head off.
She's eaten.
It's a breast tissue.
Okay.
So that was a while back.
Well,
yesterday I was out in my yard and I let
the chickens out.
I've chickens and the chickens are
wandering around and there's three
fucking hawks.
They're not big hawks.
They're small.
They're like the size of this thermos,
you know,
so probably like 12 inches high or
something.
Not a big hawk,
but they're trying to jack these
chickens.
They're there like on the chicken coop
and one of them swoops down and slams
into the Mesh like bangs into the mesh
of the chicken coop.
Like just trying to get at them.
She's a dude.
So I'm like,
this is crazy.
So I have my kids come out and my wife
come out and we're looking at these
birds swooping down and one of them
landing on top of the roof and the other
one's in the trees.
I'm like,
this is so fucking strange,
man.
What is going on?
And they're just making noise like
really loud.
They're juveniles and I've,
I've found two of them that are dead and
what I'm thinking,
the two of them that I found that are
dead are bigger.
So I did,
I saw these animals,
these small ones.
And then the next day I found a dead one
in the dead.
One a also had its head missing.
I think there's some sort of a,
a bird war going on in my neighborhood
that there's like a bird gang war going
on and I think there's hawks and there's
larger hawks.
And um,
one of my friends saw a larger hawk
eating baby hawks in a tree.
Good Lord.
Yeah,
yeah,
he was,
he was in the,
on the way down the street and uh,
apparently go into his car and he saw
these hawks that are in our neighborhood
killing these baby hawks and we're like,
what the fuck is going on?
And so I was like,
well,
so there were,
the babies were there by themselves.
They were like in the.
And then the hawks killing the babies.
Like he saw it happen.
I was like,
that is insane.
So this is like some sort of a gang war
because they told them about the hawks
being dead and he found one of them
like,
that shit is getting real in your
neighborhood.
Did it's crazy fucking hock Mageddon I
wonder.
I think it's just hawks killing other
hawks.
Like they're trying to like establish
probably just like all these other
animal.
Apparently mountain lions do that.
Two bears do that.
They'll kill young ones to find other
people's young and kill them because
they think they're competition.
There's only so many rats,
you know,
or a rabbit that the hawk and eat cad.
Fuck Dude,
that's been 10th.
So we found two,
two different hawks with no heads.
Do you normally have a lot of hawks?
Neighborhood is definitely.
You see them all the time.
You see him floating around.
There's circling all the time.
See them all the time.
You go all throughout the Hollywood
hills.
You can see him.
I don't know if I've ever seen a hug.
Maybe my friend Tom,
Tom Sharona director,
he was in his house and studio city and
he watched a,
a,
like a dove or some small bird just get
jacked by a hawk right in front of them.
It was sitting on a,
on a,
um,
a fence.
Just the burbs just sitting there
chilling.
Oh,
what a wonderful day to be a bird.
And he said this Hawk just came to swap.
Just grabbed them right there and
fucking flew off.
And they do it just for fun,
right?
They don't know.
They eat them.
They eat birds.
Do they really do birds?
The birds?
Yeah.
We played a video of owls,
Jack and hawk.
Oh yeah,
never seen that jacking a hog.
Hey.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
I've seen owls eat rabbits and shit.
Right?
They put a night vision camera on this
tree so they could capture these,
uh,
these hawks that we're in this,
this little nest together.
It might be even a young hawk and is our
will comes in from out of the sky like
you don't see anything until you see his
eyes.
He seeds floating eyes.
And then who watch this?
Watch this video.
It's amazing.
That's a hawk.
Yeah.
Watch this.
Boom.
Later.
Just Jackson his buddies like more time.
One more time.
Yeah,
let's see that again.
See the little eyes in the distance.
See how they're floating.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
This bitch.
Oh my gosh.
Crazy.
Is that so?
There you go.
There's your answer.
Birdsy Burger.
Dude.
That's intense.
Seat the fuck out of each.
I mean if you see Ethan Hawke and your
neighborhood,
you get fucking lily worried.
Looking very predatory lately.
That would be really scary.
That would be dope.
I wish my last name or Hark.
You can make it hawk,
but he did think he does names like
Ethan Wiener Schnitzel,
like got to be mysterious.
I've got to be Hawk eighth and Shama
Llama.
Dang.
There's a lot of people have done that.
Right?
Like Jamie Foxx,
he had the most brilliant idea ever.
He made his name and Androgynous name so
that he would get picked as people to go
up in the laugh factory because it was
an open mic and they would pick chicks
more than they would pick dudes because
there weren't very many chicks,
so they're trying to get a certain
amount of checks.
So he made his name ambiguous.
He changed his name to Jamie Foxx with
two x's.
That's pretty cool.
Smart.
His old standups.
Hilarious.
I used to watch this little showtime.
Suppose he's going to be on on Thursday.
Is He really?
Oh,
that's amazing.
Like I can do everything.
Yeah.
He's just bizarre.
God suddenly talented.
He can sing.
He can act like in like little
legitimate would sing and legitimately
enact act and do stand up and stand up.
Stand up some fucking hardest.
I mean,
that's to be like a monster.
He was a big headliner dude.
Did you remember when it was a monster?
It just stopped doing it.
The foxhole member,
when he had that character they did on
in living color.
The woman with the giant crazy lips.
Fucking hilarious.
Who would walk on?
He was the original duck face,
right?
Wasn't she?
Was.
Did she do that wasn't my imagining that
she made a duck face?
No,
she did.
Is that the original founder?
Right.
Can I see Wanda?
Do you think that ugly?
Wanda is the original of the duck?
Yeah.
There's the duck face.
Ugly wonder that character.
It might be the original duck fat.
That might be what?
Like what?
Everybody copies.
That's already hilarious,
right?
They're hilarious dude in living color
is a forgotten show as one of the
funniest fucking shows.
Our.
Yeah.
It was amazing to do.
Remember Handyman.
Yeah,
of course.
Do Remember File Marshal Bill.
I remember Marshall.
Bill Kinda can't stop coughing.
Um,
Fire Marshal Bill.
I was,
I was playing pool.
Me and my friend John were playing pool
in New York in this show was on a,
you know,
above the pool table and we were like,
what the fuck?
Like I can't even believe this is a real
show.
Like there would never been a show.
Like when Jim Carrey played that guy
who'd been burnt up in a fire,
never been a fucking sketch show where
they show to guy the burns all over his
face.
Like,
what the fuck?
Oh yeah.
And also remember that he had no lips a
little bit crazy.
That is insane.
Clip.
We'll also Venus de Milo.
The person was.
Did Crystal Meth,
crystal Meth,
trans weightlifter.
Like what the,
how do you even pitch that?
What a crazy show people forgot.
How about two snaps up?
Remember that?
It was amazing.
People forgot.
They forgot how good the show was.
Yeah,
they were great when we were young in
the nineties.
This was the show.
Yeah,
it was hilarious because this show is
the show that launched Jennifer,
Jennifer Lopez.
It didn't launch her.
She was a flag girl bro.
Well,
yeah,
but I mean,
but she wasn't acting on the show.
Didn't matter,
dude.
She became a fly girl.
Come on son and have some respect,
right?
No,
I'm just saying pressed,
pressed.
It's.
She's flagger.
I just.
I remember her being a flagger.
I'm saying she didn't.
That was her first thing.
Was there a freezer?
First thing,
man,
where she got her in the front.
That's turned the bottom.
Holy Fuck.
I want my money back.
What have you done?
What do you really look like?
How did you do that?
That is funny that they had.
She was the first girl I girls.
She was the first girl.
Become famous for her ass.
Right?
Not for her.
Obviously she's talented.
Don't get me wrong.
Now.
OCI,
great shape,
but she also resisted the temptation to
accentuate that ass and artificial
manner.
She's stuck with squats and dancing,
respect,
respect.
Because she was the original big booty
girl,
right?
I mean if you think about it and then
all those other chicks.
Yeah,
that's the first person I remember when
people are like,
Oh shit,
some people are taking it too far.
I saw a young lady this weekend that was
just taking it way too far.
Well,
I mean why it's a implants to me are so
bizarre.
I don't know why the fuck.
I don't know what that does.
That's a real.
But that Jennifer Lopez,
but that is a bottom.
That's,
that's legit.
That is Latina DNA.
That's exercise,
squats,
dancing,
and just the sheer love of Dick that
just just comes out in everything.
She does like,
look at that.
God Damn that woman's hot.
She's 48.
She can be 100 watts.
She's creative.
She's 100 and looks just like that.
People will line up to fuck her.
Look at her skin.
She's an insane,
insanely hot.
Some westworld shit while she's got like
super power DNA,
like there's no way you just get that
with a regular person.
That's like super power DNA.
Yeah.
No,
that's amazing.
Um,
what was the point?
It's like my skin.
Oh,
see she,
she stayed natural man.
That's the crazy thing.
Like there's so many women like and
obviously not her stature where they're
like
legit movie stars and stuff like that.
But like some of these pop gals or stuff
in so much fucking stuff into their ass
that it wiggles a waterbed themselves.
There was some.
What is the girl's name at Iggy Azalea.
Is that her name?
There's a video that she's doing what?
She's shaking her ass and it's literally
like trying to fuck in a waterbed.
It's like whoosh.
Sound effects.
It's like stop slow down.
Unless that's your real ass.
In which case multiple policies.
Multiple.
Realize your big ass shaming,
your body shaming and body shaming.
But if you have a crazy body,
we're going to talk about it.
And if you're asked that giant people
gonna talk about it.
I guess it's body shaming to be.
No,
it's.
It's a surgery shaming.
That's what it is.
I think that's legitimate to surgery.
Shame.
Sure.
Right.
If you call it like if it's like if we
had done that earlier,
would we have lost Michael Jackson?
Like if so many surgery shamed in like
soup a dude,
hey,
stop.
Yeah.
What do you.
What are you doing?
What's going on?
Why does your nose doing this?
Once you go into why is he getting so
small?
He doesn't know.
Started caving in.
Met Everyone.
Was Katie
aware?
Good Lord.
I mean I have a friend so I went to
dinner with a friend of mine.
She's awesome and I hadn't seen her for
awhile and she got plastic surgery,
plastic surgery and I didn't,
she didn't bring it up.
I hadn't seen her for like five years
and I was,
it,
it was noticeable.
Not Big Time but enough and I didn't
know how to handle it.
I didn't know what to do so I just
didn't say anything but I wanted to be
like,
why?
But,
you know,
once somebody already does it,
it's kind of a moot point to be like,
Hey,
what you do,
go back.
So I just let it go.
But it was really awkward because it
was,
she was already fucking gorgeous and
then I was,
I don't know why she did that to
herself.
So it was really,
it was really bizarre.
It's very bizarre feeling you.
Have you experienced that?
Have you had seen?
I mean,
you must've.
I have,
but my friend,
um,
even weirder was dating a girl in the
Asian girl who got that eye surgery
when.
Yeah.
And he hadn't seen her in a long time.
And then he actually told me about this.
Excuse me,
after we did the podcast,
we were talking about that eye surgery.
Remember when we showed it,
like how many Korean women in particular
are getting this crazy surgery where it
changes your face.
It makes your eyes way bigger.
They cut your lids.
Oh,
give you like this anime,
weird look.
And it's apparently super,
super popular.
He hadn't seen her in awhile and then he
saw her and she had the thing done and
he didn't recognize her.
He was like,
what?
Right.
It was like,
it was off.
It was like if I saw you and all of a
sudden your eyes were giant and had to
go,
hey,
what's up nick?
I could look at that.
Wow.
You that.
In that case it looks really good,
but I was going to say Bravo,
but it's a,
it's a weird thing that is like super,
super common to get that look.
Right.
So they go from having.
Is that a bunch of different girls who
that scares the shit out of it.
We have a friend.
I just realized who got it done.
If that's a bunch of different girls.
That freaked me the fuck out.
Have you seen him?
No,
he got it done.
You know what that is?
Of course he did the same thing with the
eyes.
Let's keep it on the DL.
Yeah,
that's why I wrote it down and show you.
But that's like your.
She's becoming westernized to see this
is what they do.
It's so crazy,
dude.
They slice your lid and then they take
like a chunk out of it.
Like say if you were cutting up a mango
in a slices,
they take a nice little mango slice and
then stitch that bad boy up and then
your lids are just way smaller.
Says nations have different need for
beauty choice.
As in Korea,
the land is small and crowded that
everyone can see can look at each other
in the face.
What the fuck he talking about?
No,
you don't like having slanty eyes.
That's all it is.
You don't like the way your eyes look.
I get it.
Don't say crazy shit unless that's a
translation problem.
Nations have different need for beauty.
Listen to this explanation.
Hey,
why do you guys have so many eye
surgeries?
Well,
in Korea the land is small and crowded
and that everybody can see can look each
other.
In that case,
the fuck.
Did you say you're.
You're on pills?
Yeah,
they got faced.
Well,
it must be some sort of a translation
issue.
I think so,
yeah.
Because like if you said that to me,
I'm like,
nick is.
I think he's gone crazy duties.
He doesn't.
The sentences don't make sense.
No,
Joe didn't do many sense.
I drunk my eyes.
Couldn't see about your face.
Hi,
what's wrong?
What was that weird?
Yeah.
No,
my friend that I hadn't seen for awhile.
I didn't know what to do.
I didn't know what to say,
so I just started screaming and threw
hot water on her face.
Oh my God.
As Taos that lives.
I could.
I started screaming.
We've got a boiling pot of water and
started yelling at the restaurant and
everybody stopped and I just ran out,
jumped into cow.
Do you remember the night of the living
dead or not?
Dead invasion of the body snatchers when
someone would turn into one of those
things and they would just be like,
just something wrong.
Yeah.
Like,
I don't know,
something's wrong with nick.
He just doesn't seem like nick anymore.
There was a slight wrong.
Nothing you wouldn't wander off and
really be an alien would find the pod,
but go find the pot under your bed,
like cobwebs and shit.
Like oh ill will.
It's like the thing.
I remember the thing I do.
That was the fucking.
It's the best movie.
One of my favorite movies of all time.
The original John Carpenter is.
Fuck
yeah.
Well that was so trippy.
That was a no.
Yeah,
that was a remake,
but it was good.
Awesome.
Phenomenal remake.
But that was so trippy because you
didn't know until they burn their blood.
Who is an alien.
So you,
you're just walk around like,
Yo,
what happened to Gary?
I don't know.
You all right,
mark?
Yeah.
Just tired.
Didn't he get the dog to it became part
of the day.
Remember that when they burned it,
they got the dog to technicals and shit.
Remember when they're doing an
operations guy,
God remember when they're doing an
operation on the guy in the chest,
opens up and becomes jaws and bites his
arms on the.
What's it called?
The Fridge?
A little simulator.
Fibulator,
defibrillators.
And it's fucking this.
Go through it.
Turned into jaws and open up and bit his
arms off.
Yeah.
That be ruled that movies.
And it holds up even though the effects
are bizarre.
It holds up.
It's still gives you like wicked anxiety
dude.
Kurt Russell.
And this movie is like one of my all
time favorite.
Yeah,
look at that.
That's crazy.
It opens up and bites on guys.
Cheers.
He could be.
He's not,
he shouldn't be.
Just say was,
is this a scene from cheers.
That's one of the last episodes.
So they cut them off.
Yeah.
They like,
these guys are going crazy.
Like Steve Your cutoff.
Remember it turned into a big spider
thing.
Yeah.
That was Kinda the head popped up legs
and started running around like a
spider.
That movie was scary as fuck,
man.
How about the end and is the best?
Don't spoiler alert.
Spoiler.
I didn't.
I didn't that Rick Baker.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's Rick Baker.
He's the special effects guy that did
American Werewolf in London is fucking
ledge.
He passed away,
right?
I do not think he did.
I think he's still alive.
Oh,
sorry.
Right.
I believe Rick Baker still alive.
I think he was just working on
something.
Something that's going on right now.
I forget what it was,
but I feel like,
uh,
there's some new project that I just
read something about.
I forget what the.
Goddamn it.
Did you see the new version of the
thing?
They did a third version.
I saw it.
I thought it was good.
I did not like it.
Oh dear.
You know,
I just thought it was.
I wanted to like it,
but I just thought it.
I thought it was bad.
Okay.
Bro.
People get mad if you don't like things
they like,
yeah bro.
You know,
maybe you suck.
You saw they turn it on,
you get mad at you,
but also I'm somebody who were like,
I wanna like shit.
So like when people are like,
oh,
you're just a hater,
it's like,
no,
I fucking go to a movie because I want
to like it.
If I watch something like I don't want
to hate something,
why would I go?
Why would I make an effort to go to a
movie to hate it?
That's fucking retarded.
I agreed to go and then I'm like,
oh,
this is,
I don't like this.
And then people go,
no you don't.
And I'm like,
no,
I don't.
I just,
I didn't like it.
It wasn't,
you know.
And I'm on your side Bro.
Thank you Jesus.
Everyone so touchy.
Yeah,
that's ridiculous.
Did you see life
with Ryan Reynolds?
I did see life.
Did you like it?
I liked it.
Did you like it Jamie?
I put it on twitter and I got attacked.
People like your flow Canadian chose
sucked.
That movie.
Blue was stupid,
was cliche.
Same Old Shit was a rebuff of aliens.
There's a lot of people that liked it,
but it was like,
it seemed like there was a good
percentage of them that hated it.
Well,
here's the thing,
it's like that critique where people go,
it's,
you know,
they took this,
this and it's like,
yeah,
movies do borrow a certain elements and
especially like life had certain stuff
that,
yeah,
devices that they used,
but it's also,
it's still,
you just have to go.
Okay.
And then like sit back and just enjoy
performances and enjoy what they made.
It's a fucking really well shot movie.
You know what it really highlighted to
me that television shows like contagious
bro.
Now you're doing it.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Television shows like house of cards in
game of thrones,
these serial shows,
they've ruined movies.
This is why,
because like to tell a story in 90
minutes or so limited,
you can only get so invested in the
character.
There's only so many different plot
twists you can have.
Like especially like this sort of a
genre,
right?
Like you take an alien life form,
it gets onboard board that people and
tries to kill him.
Okay.
How many,
how many times have we seen that?
We've seen that a thousand times in
movies,
right?
Right.
So you're gonna run into a bunch of pr
and you've got to jam it all into 90
minutes.
Like there's certain things that have to
be like plot mechanisms.
They have to take place.
Like the alien has to attack the first
person.
You're going to see it coming.
There's going to be like a bunch of shit
going on.
You have to adhere to certain cliches.
Got Devices.
That's that.
People that the Jew like prometheus's I
did like I didn't like is I didn't love
it and I liked the new alien.
I didn't see the new alien,
but I heard it's awesome.
It's great.
I mean I liked both of them.
I got a lot of shit for that.
People are like,
you're a fucking idiot.
And I was like,
easy grandma.
Be hanging around with me.
And what is that?
No,
it wasn't my ground.
Nobody know,
but people I do hang out with people
that are critical like director friends
and shit,
but oh,
directors of the worst to watch a movie
with.
Yeah,
they're pretty bad director people
because they're,
they're so beyond critical,
but like I'm critical of comedy.
It's like when I go to comedies,
I walk out of a lot of them because I
just.
I'm like,
you know what the worst is if you.
You're around actors that haven't made
it.
Actors that like barely work negative.
I don't even understand that choice.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
That's really bad.
Whatever happened to his career,
you're like,
that's Daniel Day Lewis.
What's his middle of the day?
And his crew are really fell off after
that movie.
Somebody said that about the dude and
Jurassic Park.
My keys in fucking Jurassic Park.
It's one of the biggest movies of all
time.
Everyone's career falls off after
Jurassic Park.
Okay.
It's no way to get bigger.
You stupid.
Fuck.
Like I'm sure the guy probably did a lot
of movies after Jurassic fucking park
also.
Maybe he made enough money that he
doesn't have to do movies anymore.
You twat right?
Yeah.
He's his fucking Jurassic dollars
and can I have my latte?
I'm tired of this.
Who's his choice?
His career.
His career totally dropped off.
Did you say nonfat nonfat soy,
nonfat soy sugar free please?
Yeah,
it is funny.
Like,
I'll uh,
I'll do interviews for stuff and they'll
be like,
yeah man,
I'm just looking over your stuff.
Why did you do that movie?
And I'm like,
because my friend was in it and he asked
me to do it because I suck.
Like I fucking.
Yeah.
I'm friends with people and they were
doing a project and they're like,
hey,
you want to do this?
I'm like,
all right,
I'm not going to go.
No,
fuck you man.
My friend.
Like,
yeah,
there's other variables besides,
you know.
Yeah man.
I was willing to do your assassin show.
Exactly there.
It says right there.
You would do that.
Trust me.
Exactly.
I didn't even look into it.
Yeah.
That could find out like halfway into
the filming,
Nick eats a pound of adderall a day,
a full pound of adderall.
They,
they,
they deliver it in pounds.
He just on adderall.
He doesn't even know he's making a
movie.
He just found out it's a movie.
I thought he was in a dream about making
a movie.
You just found out he's actually making
He has no,
he thought it was at the fit,
so he hasn't slept in a year.
Just one year,
no sleep.
This guy puts adderall on his foot and
then kicks it in the next mouth thing.
If you didn't sleep for a long time but
you were still up moving,
you would probably just start.
Just start hallucinating,
right?
Isn't that what people did right?
Was the story.
I did a show in Tahoe riders on the
storm riders.
I did a show in Tahoe and I forgot to be
hydrated so I didn't get hydrated at
all.
And so I didn't drink any water and I
was drinking on the plane that me and my
buddy got an arena and he drove a Tahoe.
We were drinking in Tahoe and I did my
show.
We just kept drinking.
I didn't drink any water.
And then I got back.
I was up like,
I dunno,
maybe like 15 hours.
And then,
uh,
I kept drinking and like didn't really
think about it.
And I'm at the Casino,
I'm having fun.
And then I started feeling sick and then
um,
I tried to go to bed and I can't.
And then,
so I'm awake throughout the night and
then the next day I'm like still awake
and I'm like kind of panicking now
because I haven't slept for like over 24
hours.
And now I have,
like,
I've realized that I have altitude
sickness because I had my puking and
then I haven't,
so I'm starting to drink water.
So I got,
I drank and I had alcohol poisoning and
altitude sickness and sleep deprivation.
So I flew home to La and I had slept for
like 30 fucking six hours and I'm in my
bed.
I'm like,
I got to go to sleep so I get in my bed
and then,
uh,
I just start hearing like music and like
all this stuff and like people,
like there was a party next door but
there was no party.
And then so I was like,
what the fuck?
And then I'm lying in my bed and I just
hear pounding on my floor.
And I was like,
what the fuck?
And I heard like legitimate,
like pounding.
And I was like totally awake and I
realized I hadn't slept and then I like
took like a sunlight,
some sleeping,
like at some Nyquil or something.
And then I finally got to bed cheese.
But it was super weird,
man.
Yeah.
I've heard people that do those races,
those ultra marathon races,
they start seeing shit that's not their
cam.
Didn't have that happen to him.
But I've heard other people,
they see people on the side of the road
waving at them that aren't even there.
Really did altitude we ever got out suit
fucks with me real bad.
My friend Ben,
Ben,
Brian who was on the show last week,
the week before last,
he was talking about how he was in Nepal
and he was getting out to sickness while
he's in Nepal and he saw a baby on the
side of the road and there was no baby.
And he saw a wolf saw wolves.
Like two guys.
There's a wolf is a wolf.
And they're like,
oh my God,
how many know what he's way the fuck up
there.
Yeah,
bugs are bad.
You know,
he's above 13,000
feet.
And uh,
and he was sick too.
He was.
Everybody got food poisoning.
So he calls food poisoning and altitude
sickness.
Oh.
And it was just seeing things.
It's not a baby.
He's like,
you guys don't see that baby.
Nobody was like,
oh my God,
you see a baby,
it's a baby.
Just chill on the side of the road.
It'd be like,
look,
look closer at the baby.
And then I just pushed him off.
Deuces you,
that Guy Deuces dot.
You're the one who cuts his losses.
Like this guy is not going to make it.
Bang.
I've got to think about survival.
The group,
man,
your buddy would not survive around me.
Do last.
And think how you would've handled
things differently.
I never saw last summer.
So I went up to sewed,
never saw one episode.
I've heard that.
I watch it.
Yes,
up until like the last season and then
quit.
I heard it.
I heard it kind of jumped ship last
season.
It was like they're all standing around
while there's a pool that brings you
back to life.
And no one's freaking out.
Like,
what is wrong?
What the fuck?
Kind of show my watching.
Did you guys forget?
The people have to believe this shit.
Okay.
What do you do?
They're just standing around there and
like that perfect order that you do on
sitcoms was the person talking here and
there's another person talking about
with that never happens in real life.
The perfect blocking.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Blocking and we let people look at each
other.
You fucking asshole.
You all standing around.
No one's freaking out.
There's a pond that brings people back
to life and you guys are just phoning it
in.
I think that's why I jumped ship and
excited to see derailed.
Super Bad.
And then I heard the.
The writers didn't think it was going to
go that long and so they ran out of shit
that.
So that somebody told me that they were
like,
yeah,
we didn't think it was.
We weren't really ready
in the beginning though.
The beginning.
It's so good.
It's such a good show for the first,
like she knows how many seasons I binge
watched was like five or six,
right?
Yeah.
Up until the last season it started to
fall apart.
He died,
I fell apart,
spoiler alert.
It's that many people on the show.
And our boy dominic who was on the show
has been on this podcast.
My funny,
my buddy,
uh,
Jorge Garcia.
And then what happened to kind of
overweight,
uh,
won the lottery and there's the girl,
that girl from last.
She did it.
Oh,
she was one of the girls
in the hobbit movie.
Yeah.
She was like an Elf elf chick hot as
fuck.
She the elephants.
And then.
So as Dominic Monaghan.
Yeah.
He was enough to.
She was hot.
No,
no.
Dominic was something else.
Wasn't the hobbit.
He was a hobbit.
Yeah.
One of my favorite moments.
I was in an additional one time years
ago,
and the Lord of the rings,
you just come out and I had seen it and
we were auditioning for some shitty
movie and he was in the waiting room and
they came out and they're like,
we're running about 40 minutes behind.
I was like,
are you fucking kidding me?
He was like,
Jesus,
man,
what the hell?
And I go,
why?
What are you doing here?
And he goes,
what do you mean?
I go,
you were just in Lord of the rings.
And he goes,
yeah.
and I go there,
they shouldn't make you wait 40 minutes,
dude.
That would be fucking mad.
And he was like,
you're right.
I go,
yeah,
no shit.
I go fucking call your agent,
man.
You're a fucking in the rear.
One of the rings of the Lord.
Will you do doing that?
Just to kick him out of there so that
you can get the.
No,
I would have let him go in front of me.
I'm the good guy.
Wow.
I was like,
I would have been failed.
dude,
you're in the biggest movie of the
world.
Put that picture back up once.
See something here.
I forgot all these characters.
Now remembering them when I'm seeing
this again.
Remember the Middle Eastern guy was
named his name.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He was a first Middle Eastern do to get
the fuck white chicks in a big time
show,
right?
He had a hot white girlfriend did there.
Keith urban is on it.
No,
that's not keith.
Urban pro.
Dare you and then there's the Korean guy
who was in Hawaii five o and he just,
they want to believe in Hawaii.
They're pissed off.
They were saying that they don't get
enough respect like the Asian actors
weren't getting paid as much as the
white actors and Hawaii.
Five o.
That was the complaint.
I don't know if it's true.
I don't know if I would complainant.
If I was on a show in Hawaii,
I'd be like,
yeah,
just pay me and fucking Doritos.
I don't give a shit dude.
I think after awhile you just get tired
of everything you're doing.
If you're doing somebody show and in
paradise you tired of being impaired.
I said,
bet right.
Don't they say people get island fever.
They moved to like a Wahoo and then
after awhile I'm like,
I gotta get Outta here.
I can't do that as well.
Right.
I guess I don't know if I could.
I would love to do that.
That's a fever I would not mind getting.
Do you see yourself living in Maui in
the future?
Yeah,
my buddy.
We'll put a bar there.
You buddy opened a bar in Maui?
Yeah.
And he said,
um,
I opened a bar,
it's a true story,
and I go,
can I get a job?
And he goes,
what do you mean?
I go,
I don't know,
can I?
What can I bartend?
What if you was like,
yeah,
the House Mc.
I don't want to fucking be the house.
I'm seeing them just have a microphone
and start talking to people away from
Bob.
That sounds horrible.
That went from really per Paris paradise
sick.
Is that a word?
Yeah.
To know?
I don't want to be a fucking.
I don't know.
I don't want a microphone.
It would be nice to like,
bartend and be like,
yeah,
Robin Cook a couple of my tabs over
here.
Just be like cocktail.
You know what I mean?
They can give you a sweet apartment
above the bar and you wake up with a
pounding headache every day because
you're just drinking yourself to death.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Sign
me up.
Sound of the water crashing into the
bottom of the building.
Hit some way is like stone pylons and
hold this bar up and it's elevated over,
partially elevated over the water.
Eat some leeching off the tree.
Fresh leg.
It's really a contradiction.
It's a conundrum because you're in
paradise.
It's the most beautiful place on earth.
It's peaceful.
You're relaxed,
you've given away all your personal
belongings.
You're a pure minimalist.
Now what do you have?
You have a few pairs of shorts,
some flip flops,
and a microphone.
Case.
The microphone downstairs breaks because
that's what you do.
Now you go down and talk to people.
Go down tonight,
Nick d do standup anymore.
Well,
can I do stand up?
I don't have a mic,
but you know,
they never know when I'm coming.
I have a mic.
So yeah,
it's kind of whenever I want to do it.
Immediately you telling me you wouldn't
go to a bar if you knew that every night
Joey Diaz was going to take a microphone
and just start walking through the crowd
and talking shit.
A hundred percent.
I would do that 100 percent.
Yeah.
But that's Joey Diaz.
Like,
um,
I wouldn't be good at that.
It wouldn't be now,
but you got to get better.
Okay.
Can you get better at being a bar guy?
Bar EMC?
EMC.
It's a skill man.
Like anything else,
like playing golf,
like jerking off,
you get better at it.
Right?
It doesn't make sense.
It doesn't,
but I think it does.
No.
Maybe you could just be like,
you turn to a singer.
Everybody's like Nikki.
She really tell jokes again.
No Man.
I'm Jimmy Buffett songs.
What?
I make my voice though.
So I'm like diarrhea and have everybody
clap.
Yeah,
he could have like funny songs.
Yeah.
That's the move,
right?
I'm on board.
Right?
I hope I get to go to dinner.
Joe,
where you going?
I'm going to leave right now.
You can play.
It's pretty soon.
You're going to a vegan place.
Dude.
You're healthy and up.
What are you doing?
I know,
I'm trying to,
uh,
just,
just kind of get back into shape.
Yeah.
So getting back into the gym and uh,
I'm in.
I've been pretty good with my diet.
I'm getting kind of fascinated by diet.
So I've been off dairy for eight years.
Whoa.
And then,
uh,
I've been pretty much cut out sugar.
I have like dark chocolate if I really
like start craving shit,
but I'm trying to like really get my
body.
I'm like really fascinated by diets by
new fascination.
Well,
you find the difference,
right?
You eat healthy.
The difference.
When I quit eating dairy and it was some
random dude at a juice bar who worked
there and I was always sick and he was
like,
hey man,
you're always six words in.
And I go,
yeah.
And he was like,
do you eat a lot of dairy?
And I go,
yeah,
he goes,
do this.
He goes,
quit eating dairy for two weeks.
See how you feel.
He's like cold Turkey.
And I go,
okay,
fuck it.
So I did.
And I haven't been back in eight years.
My sleep,
everything.
My stomach never got sick,
never got migraines.
It changed everything.
And then I got super fascinated by that.
I still drank by tits off,
you know what I mean?
Have you tried raw milk?
No.
Apparently some people have an issue
with homogenized and pasteurized milk
and they don't have it with raw milk or
they don't have it with goats
milk too.
Especially raw goat's milk.
I've heard about goats milk.
I just want to just bypass all of it.
I do like almond milk and rice milk.
Yeah,
well it's,
it's a,
it's an ethical thing to bypass to if
you really stop and think about it
because there's something fucking creepy
about mass produced like handles yanking
on titties and these cows that are like
kind of perpetually pregnant.
Like isn't that what they are?
They're the cows.
Like they're constantly nursing.
Right.
So they're,
they're,
they make them get knocked up nor to
have the milk come out.
Right.
The milk doesn't just come,
it's out in there.
Their nursing.
It's a little weird.
I don't know.
It's weird.
It's fucking weird.
But I want to try to fuck with going
Vegan for a little bit and just see how
it is.
So you know,
so far how long you been doing it?
Two days.
But I mean,
for the most part,
I don't really eat a lot of red meat and
uh,
I mean I eat like chicken and fish,
but I'm going to try to go vegan.
I'm going to try to do it for like two
weeks,
you know,
one way that you can get protein that's
very ethical and um,
you don't even have to think about it
too much is scallops and muscles and
things along those lines when you eat,
I'm the fuck.
Are they called mollusks?
Is that the word?
Shellfish.
Shellfish is what I'm looking for.
Shellfish in particular,
like especially like clams and oysters,
oysters and things along those lines.
They're so primitive.
They don't even have nervous systems.
We just think of them as like an animal,
like a living creature because they can
move and close this.
But a venus fly trap is probably way
more sophisticated and it's a plant way
more sophisticated in organism than
that.
And then,
especially if you're talking about those
acacia trees,
they'll have this communications that
there's nothing going on like that with
mollusks.
They're like really stupid.
There was super ancient life forms that
are kind of meat,
but they're almost like what we're
talking about,
like that fucking gelatinous thing
inside of the box.
That's what they're like.
You could eat it.
Yeah.
Scallops are amazing.
I mean,
I've had scallops.
They're amazing because they will.
Yes.
Oh,
scalp is a mosque like clams and mussels
and mosque.
Oh,
that's a genre expert.
Five minutes ago.
Can you remember the name of it?
I just forgot,
but scallops are amazing,
but those things are like a good way.
Oysters,
they're a good way to get protein.
A lot of them is sustainable.
A lot of those things are sustainable
because they actually make like farms
have them.
They grow them on the ground the same
way you would grow fruit.
They grow them on the ground of an ocean
obviously,
but the same way you would grow fruit or
grow vegetables,
like you can grow these things and
they're a good source of quote unquote
animal protein in an ethical way.
Like these things are so primitive.
They have like they're,
they're,
they're not feeling shit.
Like they're not getting bummed out that
you're eating right.
They just clamped down and closed.
They were like super duper high in
protein.
Yeah,
very high in protein.
Really good for you.
I'm oysters are a good way to,
especially oysters in olive oil.
It's a good way to stay in a fat based
diet like Ketogenic Diet because there's
so much fat
in them for the olive oil and then the
oysters themselves.
Very,
very healthy for you.
Yeah.
Really good for your body.
I got sick from noise because I had too
many at one time,
but there's a different,
different story.
You know,
raw oysters.
You really got to get fresh.
What are you talking about?
Talking about cooked,
smoked oysters.
You getting like cans?
Like I take them with me on the road.
I'll tell you a buy them in bulk and
I'll take them with me on the road.
So I have healthy snacks like in my
hotel rooms.
And Oysters isn't bad for you?
No,
no.
I'm sure like there's some leaching of
all sorts of different things.
When you put something into a container.
I wouldn't.
I wouldn't say she eat it every day
because I used to eat sardines every
day,
but I turned positive for arsenic.
They found traces of arsenic in my
system and they were like deadly.
It is,
but apparently it's just one of the
heavy metals that is a at the bottom of
the ocean that's affected by pollution.
The levels of it are affected by
pollution and so these sardines are
particularly the kind of bottom feeders
and if you're in a polluted area and you
get sardines from polluted area,
they'll have heavy metals in them,
you know like mercury,
Mercury here that.
So I got off the sardines for awhile and
went back and got tested.
It was a hundred percent clean.
They were like,
it's gotTa,
be the sardines.
I said,
totally makes sense.
Can't eat them every day,
bro.
I was eating like three or four cans a
day,
like three or four kids.
Anything is high in sodium.
Two sodiums.
Okay.
Just drink as long as you drink water.
Sodium was fine.
Like the idea that there's a,
a total misconception about sodium
causing high blood pressure and heart
attacks.
That was all based on a bullshit study
at.
Somebody pushed through what?
What was that study like?
Sodium does not cause high blood
pressure.
Go Google that because there was this
whole bogus study that people keep
repeating over and over again about
salt.
Obviously you have too much of anything
to kill you,
right?
Like we talked about,
water.
Water will fuck you up too much.
Salt will definitely kill you.
Too many star trek a pound of salt.
You're fucking dead,
man.
You're a dead man.
You can eat a pound of meat.
It's time to end the war on salt.
Zealous drive by politicians to limit
our salt intake has little basis in
science.
Yeah,
it's bullshit.
Not only that,
it's an essential mineral like you need
salt,
salt.
Is it really important that you don't
want to have too much of it?
Absolutely.
That meaning like you don't want to
cover everything in Salt.
Just like you don't want to drink too
much water,
just like you don't want to eat too much
fruit.
Like if you eat too many oranges,
it's not good.
You get 100 oranges is not good for you.
It's horrible.
So much sugar.
Yeah.
But to have a good healthy amount of
salt in your diet,
especially like Himalayan salts,
really good minerals that shit's
ancient.
These things are like Himalayan salt.
That's salt crystal thing.
That lamp,
that salt water.
If you ate that,
see that one over there and it's lit.
What if you ate that?
Probably super good.
Make Your Dick hard as a rock that um,
that thing's supposed to like emit
energy man.
Feels like it wasn't at.
It's over there.
We,
you,
Jamie.
Remind me to replace the battery in that
one or whatever the fuck it needs.
It doesn't need a new bowl.
Just duck.
Duck like Oh fuck.
We're at burn me.
Yeah.
Don't fuck with it.
Did it shouldn't?
No.
Dude.
Is it plugged in?
Plugged in anymore?
I think I unplugged it.
I hope you wrote off.
It doesn't work and just keep it plugged
in while it's just in there cooking.
I cut back on smoking.
Yeah,
I've been good with my diet.
I'm like really fascinated by it.
So you got somebody doing this for you.
You talking to a nutritionist?
Eating Shit and just going by he makes
sure that you you get what you really
should do really should do and I can
send you to a guy is go to a real good
doctor that specializes in nutritional
profiles and get your blood work done
and let them find out like,
do you need maybe you need nice and you
need vitamin D,
need vitamin B like here you are low in
this or you're low in that.
There's a lot of stuff that people
neglect in there and didn't even know.
You know,
you don't know until you actually get
your blood work done.
You don't know what's low.
What's.
I do want to do that.
I mean I'd take a lot of vitamins and
stuff and I asked her.
I think I,
I kind of like,
I'm doing a decent job just going rogue.
That was my last tattoo by the way.
How drunk were you when you.
I was actually pretty deezer.
I got him.
I got to Vegas.
Why did you decide to write rogue and
your arm and was me and my buddies and
we'd go like one more like partying and
like my buddy will text me like,
hey,
you want to go to the gym?
And I'm like,
I'm going fucking rogue.
Then that just means that it's gonna I'm
signing up for your vendor.
Good partier though,
Dude.
Oh,
tell you I've run into you going rogue
many times and it's never been anything
but hugs and laughs.
Oh yeah.
No,
I'm like a really good drunk,
like I know how to do it and I know I'm
not like people like see me.
Like I post photos and shit.
I'm always,
you know,
out like raging and I'm not always
raging but when I do it's really
controlled.
It's not like you're good at it.
I've,
I've built up a tolerance of an I know
what I'm doing.
Like I don't just do any shot that's
handed to me and just like I,
I dunno,
I,
I keep it very simple.
But yeah,
I get really fired up.
I just,
I love drinking and going out.
Yeah.
I've never like fighter guy or I'm never
like Moody Dark Guy.
That's the worst.
The depressed cry guy.
So Jesus,
will you stop.
Why are you crying all over?
He broke up.
It happens.
Yeah.
So for you.
I'll never quit drinking drinking's to
fun though.
Thank you.
Know it said that I.
Yeah,
I don't.
I mean I'll take break.
I liked drinking.
It's fun.
I don't like the effects of it on the
body,
but it's,
that's the,
that's the fucking tradeoff.
The tradeoff is it's fun for a little
while and then you're like,
oh,
was in Italy?
I drink wine every night.
I was in Italy.
I just got back.
I drank wine seven nights in a row.
Uh,
drank many glasses of wine.
I passed a seven nights in a row.
I totally went off the rails with my
diet.
I gained five pounds of to.
It's Italy.
That's what I'm saying,
Dawg.
Shit,
yeah.
You got to go off the rails and enjoy
yourself.
But it's fun to go off the rails and get
back on the rails and you appreciate
being on the rails unlike the way you
think.
Yeah.
But you're like,
you're not a drunk that I'd ever avoid.
If I see this.
Certain people,
we all know them.
You see them drunk and you're like,
oh no,
I can't be responsible for this.
I gotta get Outta here.
Yeah.
No,
it's scary.
There's some comics where I'm like,
Ooh,
I gotTa Babysit,
Babysit this person.
There's some dark motherfuckers
completion.
So that to me,
broom,
like,
oh my God,
I can't do this.
Can't do this.
I can't read your texts.
I can't help you with this.
This is yours.
Yeah.
People go bad.
Rogue Scott.
My kids,
Bro.
Okay.
I got it.
Hey,
look at the time.
You're not thinking rational.
You're drunk.
Party didn't do a family.
Meanwhile in the middle of it,
like he's gone through tinder,
swiping the fucking worst.
I lost one of my best friends who is
like one of my road fucking buddies.
And He,
uh,
my roommate was friends with his ex
girlfriend and they were watching a
movie and I came home and I went to bed
and said hi to him.
And then the next day he like flipped
out on me and I texted him.
I go,
what's up man?
He's like,
my ex girlfriend was at air,
fucking house.
I go,
yeah,
it was watch a movie with my buddy.
And he's like,
what the fuck man?
It's like he didn't tell me fuck you.
And then I never talked to me again.
So you were supposed to tell him that
his ex girlfriend is dating your buddy?
Yeah.
It's like,
well it was so bizarre and he's one of
my best friends and he won't talk to me.
That you wouldn't,
didn't tell him about it.
Yeah.
And it's been a year and he won't talk
to me anymore.
Whoa.
Now does he,
did he want you to stop it in some way?
I don't know.
I never found out.
That doesn't make any sense.
So I could understand like if you want,
if you told him he would just get bummed
out.
Right.
Well that's the thing.
They were just watching a movie.
It wasn't like a,
but they weren't dating.
It was just really weird.
Anyway,
my point being is that while you around
soon as you got out of the room,
it was a love song,
but it's like it's like bad road friend
that just gets fucking needs this,
you know,
I,
I just can't deal with drama.
Like when I go out,
I don't want drama and nobody does.
I think what we're talking about
earlier,
how chimps have this horrific behavior.
I think there's some of that leftover
and people,
and I think it comes out when you get
involved in relationships and breakups.
I think you see that angry chimp come
out sometimes.
Oh yeah.
Alcohol is one of those things.
Obviously it affects not just even
alcohol,
so jealousy too though.
Just jealousy as well.
Yeah,
but also,
but jealousy fueled with alcohol,
which is a disaster.
I mean you look at the people that are
in jail right now because they got drunk
and got jealous and pulled out a gun or
pulled out a baseball bat and just went
and then add coke to that and you get
confident,
crazed,
righteous.
I'll show her like you live in in some
stupid two dimensional movie,
like you don't even thinking about the
consequences.
Can't even cocaine.
I can't even.
I can't even do it.
I never got really into it.
I mean,
I definitely did it,
but I was never one of those guys that
was just.
I mean I have friends still that go hard
in the paint with that and they're like
creeping into their forties and they're
still every weekend.
Dunkin has a great bit on adderall that
I wish I had adderall and cocaine that I
wish I could share with the audience.
You'll have to go see him.
Duncan trussell live in New York City.
Love you don.
During the last end up,
he moved.
He's happy there.
I'm really upset because he liked it.
I was hoping he hated it.
He's living in Brooklyn.
He's like the king of Brooklyn.
I can see him like in Brooklyn.
They took him in and they gave him fresh
hats.
He's like,
hey guys.
Hey guys.
You're sweet e's.
He did a recent podcast,
folks with Aubrey.
Aubrey Marcus.
It's amazing.
It's really good.
His live podcasts are incredible,
really good.
He's got a fucking cult.
Duncan's essentially running a colt.
He's.
He would be the best caught later.
He has a house.
Omer.
Here's a guy who was like the House Ohm
guy.
Now the guy did ohm and did.
Oh,
I'm so good.
And his name was like fucking bobby.
Something like shallow Monga,
some fucking ancient ingesting Swami
Swami rick or something like that and
this guy does an ome in front of his
live audience and it was so good.
Will you be the household?
Really?
Yeah.
That guy's a house home guy.
Every time.
Dunkin doesn't show that.
Guys going to do owns for them.
Oh good Lord.
He has a chance that he does.
We,
we,
we've done it before.
Like in audiences.
We started off a show with it once.
It didn't work.
It was a disaster.
It was a terrible idea.
We started off a show where we all got
on stage and had the audience ohm and
then Duncan went,
did stand up,
but there were so weirded out by the
time they were like,
what the fuck are you guys doing?
So we did it a couple of times,
we did a couple of times to like breath
blessed the show.
I remember when I had my twitch channel
to Duncan does a twitch stream every so
often and what is he doing here?
He is a Watt James Corden dancing in
some way,
but he had a mask on and was holding a
thing.
Of course it's pretty fun to watch.
Yeah,
he's out of his mind.
Don't get and wrote on my vagina mask is
that a vagina?
Looks like a vagina,
vagina,
mask.
I had my show on comedy central,
pretend time,
a sketch show and it was like really
aggressive and weird.
So I was like,
Oh Duncan,
you got to write on it.
So I brought Dunkin onto right.
And every sketch he would hand in,
I was always like,
all right,
what the fuck is this going to be?
And it was so insane.
Yeah.
Like you're playing like a pussy and
makes shit that
like elves and like the I can juggle
knives and then they like each other's
ass.
That was
a psycho.
I would have to like just every sketch
or try to find what is arable out of it,
but I mean there were like obviously
moments of brilliance,
but were sometimes I was like,
dude,
what the fuck is this?
What in the fuck indeed.
Nick Swardson don't change your
beautiful.
Thank you.
And you play a good game of pool,
sir.
I'm in your shows.
Still available.
People could see that.
Typical Rick,
me and dirt nasty.
It's the guy who directed grandma's boy.
You're at the comedy store all the time.
You're touring all the time.
Getting ready for my new next netflix
special coming out shit and doing that.
I don't know yet.
I might be.
I was going to be next spring,
but it might be sooner because the sets
are coming together,
but yeah,
all my dates are posted on Rio.
Nick Swardson,
instagram and twitter and website.
You have a website or you just don't do
that anymore?
The websites coming up.
I just.
We're developing it right now so it'll
be up soon,
but I'll post on my social media and
then I got a bunch of dates up until
Christmas,
so.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Well if you haven't seen nick lives.
Fucking hilarious.
Thanks dude,
and this was a lot of fun,
man.
Yeah,
me like six years.
I now.
It's fucking nuts.
We see each other all the time.
We did this.
We did a podcast six years ago,
but we did it more often.
We'll do more often.
I'm going to do the laser blast
campaign,
I'm sure down for that.
That's going to happen,
so we'll do that as soon as we set up
the new studio,
which should be within the next month or
so.
All right,
thanks everybody.
Dorian Yates for multiple time.
Mr Olympia,
mother dot.